at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O well hey everybody it's Wednesday
night yeah time for the main show it's
the main show about Anthrax the anthrax
care and demonetized no just kidding
probably
not I remember when it happened I do as
well and then the whole
[__] Saga of who did it that went on
for seemingly years and years and by
that time I didn't give a [__] well it
did well see that's the thing because I
remember very vividly like when this
first happened because when it happened
cuz I was older I was in my 20s and I
was working I was at my job because I
remember what happened and um so I kind
of remember it happening but then
because the investigation went on so
long they didn't really figure out who
they thought it was it's technically
still unsolved but they think they know
who it was but I don't know we'll get
into that but by the time that that
happened it was like seven years later
so I think a lot of I you know they did
report it in the media and [__] like
that but it's just like by that point I
was just didn't really know because when
I started researching this I was like oh
I vividly remembered like when it first
happened but I was like what the [__]
happened with that I don't even remember
what the [__] happened with that it's
like I'm sure I heard about it but it's
like it didn't stick for whatever reason
but yeah so I had to go back into it
there's actually a decent documentary on
Netflix about this it's not a series
it's just a standalone and it's like an
hour and a half it's not fantastic it
does like lag a little bit like asz Tom
was watching it going there's kind of a
lot of filler in this which there
slightly was but um there's some other a
couple other YouTube uh shows that were
good about it too that kind of went more
into the dude who they think it was like
went into his background and stuff which
I actually thought was kind of
interesting the documentary that they
have on Netflix they actually have an
actor who the [__] is that actor he was
on that show that's I know that really
narrows it down to that you know that
actor from that show you know the dude
the dude with the head you know what I
mean dud they had those shoes it was
that guy I can't remember what his name
is but it's like he was on I'll think of
it in a minute but like he was on some
kind of big show that I used to watch
and he plays uh you know Dr Bruce Ivans
the guy that they think it was because
obviously that guy is dead um so they
did like reenactments and they had him
like reading some of the dude's real
emails and stuff like that dude was um
I'm going to say I uh you know I I'm not
privy to all the information that the
FBI was privy to so I don't know and
they don't really know if this dude
really did it or not and like I said
he's dead now so they can't really they
were just kind of like yeah it was
probably him but that's about all we can
do and I'm going to say i' probably
Fallen that I don't know it does seem
like he had the opportunity for sure uh
there was a lot of circumstantial
evidence against him but it's just
slightly possible that it could have
been somebody else although the [__] did
stop as far as we know the thing about
this kind of botet terrorism attack
which is kind of the first one that had
happened this is like the first one like
this that had happened on American soil
like ever right far as I remember yes
well no there were corporations back in
the 1800s handing out handed out small
pox and I get yeah you could consider
that bi all kinds of stuff that was
happening but this I think this was the
first thing of this nature that it
happened in this particular way but the
thing about it is that because it sent
through the mail and because Anthrax is
a naturally occurring bacteria like you
can get it just from dirt or
contaminated meat or something like that
doesn't necessarily mean I thought it
was a Spore it is yeah but it's yeah
it's a bacterium though all right you
just that's just that's just um spores
is just kind of the way that you pick it
up that's the vector right yeah okay so
um so you can get it naturally it's it's
rare but it does happen so when somebody
came up with it because it's so rare
they didn't really think of it oh
somebody's got Anthrax you know what I
mean and then when they found out it was
Anthrax because it was just one person
they didn't really jump to the
conclusion oh they got it through the
mail or it was terrorism or anything
like that they just thought he got it
some natural way because that's usually
what would happen and I think the the
people that died from this CU five five
people did end up dying none of the
people
that that the um the anthrax was
actually mailed to because other people
ended up opening it or the people that
works in worked in the post office where
it went through like end up dying and
[__] like that which is shitty but you
know I'm not saying it would have been
better if the people that were the the
targets got killed that also would have
been awful but I'm just saying that it
was like collateral damage and I believe
22 other people were infected but
survived because the thing about this
particular strain of Anthrax which we
will get into is that um it was a
particularly uh strong variant and um
also the the way that it was um you know
the way that it was
administered it was from inhaling and
that particular kind of Anthrax because
there's a couple different kinds um is I
believe between 80 and 90%
fatal so it's uh it's bad news if you
get it that's for sure and um even if
you survive it it does cause some like
lingering effects uh and things like
that so it's not a fun time all around
um but yeah so this was kind of
interesting to delve back into I think
it was one of you guys' idea cuz I
thought we had done a show about this
but then I remembered that the show I
was thinking of was the Chicago Tylenol
poisonings that happened in the 80s we
did do a show about that um I'm I've
always had kind of a Fascination about
these kind of like Mass poisonings like
this cuz this when this first happened
obviously because it happened like you
know the first letter was sent out like
a week after 911 so everybody thought it
was related right that it was just like
you know this is Islamic terrorists and
blah blah um but you know it turned out
not to be that probably um so the the
motives behind if if the guy that they
think did it was actually the dude that
did it his motives were like weird you
know what I mean yeah maybe they were
not sure entirely what his motives are
but he was um he was a weird dude he was
a weird dude Islamic radicals they'd
have a bigger supply of this they we use
a lot more of it yeah I I don't think
they could have get hold of it anyway
yeah I think really I remember vaguely
when this happened and obviously you
know when they first realized that this
was you know a biot terrorism attack
like going through the mail um you know
obviously the first thing they would
think was that it was related to 911 and
espe and as we'll get into um whoever
was doing it was very keen to make
people think that because of like some
letters the letters that were in there
yeah but when they found out that it was
actually just like an American dude um
who didn't seem to have any political
agenda he was just
maybe maybe crazy yeah and angry about
something or other I'm not entirely sure
what it may or may not be this guy yeah
I mean I tend to think it probably is
just because like I said all the
evidence is circumstantial but it's a
lot of circumstantial evidence you know
what I mean so even though they don't
have like sorry I have like a piece of
hair that's like right in my eyeball and
I can't get it but um you know even
though they don't have like a super
Smoking Gun thing but all of the
evidence that they have does kind of
make him look pretty guilty but it is
possible that he's not but like I said
he's dead so I guess we'll never know
unless they catch another person and
they figure out that that person did it
which I guess is still possible it's odd
that it was Anthrax though that's a very
retro old-fashioned bio weapon it is and
it's not very good it's it it defeats a
lot of the the reasons why you would
want to use a biow
weapon if you use Anthrax you know it's
a weapon because it's just it doesn't
occur naturally in in large amounts you
know and the whole reason why you'd ever
want to use a biow weapon it was to deny
that you used it right you're like yeah
your enemies they're all dying from some
kind of plague we had nothing to do with
it that's not that you know that's that
was natural that's a natural plague
that's hitting them that that's what
that's what saves you from
retaliation yeah cuz you're just like
who me I didn't do that yeah like yeah
don't you dare nature did that [__] yeah
right it's very clandestine and stealth
well thousands and thousands of people
start coming down with Anthrax you know
a weapon was used yeah and this one like
I said it wasn't a lot of people and it
was very small scale Anthrax does occur
in nature as I mentioned but it's very
very rare for somebody to come down with
it so much so that when somebody turned
up with the symptoms they didn't
initially know that it was that because
they hadn't seen it before and honestly
when this happened in 2001 the last
person to die from Anthrax in the United
States as far as I know like from my
research was in 1976 and that was like
natural so you doctors that were on the
you know they they wouldn't have jumped
to that conclusion because they just had
never seen it you know what I mean
probably Untold other [__] out there
lurking that we don't know about to oh
I'm sure and it's probably better not to
think about it too hard because like I
said do you remember for a time we were
kind of obsessed with that show what was
it called The Monsters Inside Me
Monsters Inside Me which was all about
it wasn't just diseases sometimes it was
[__] like pieces of pieces of milk like
a piece of the grill brush that somebody
swallowed in a hamburger and it like
[__] their [__] all up oh my God I was
horrified I was like I'm never eating
anything ever again yeah like off the
grill anyway I'm like let's get some
yeah because it was just like one Little
Brush and it just didn't it poke a hole
in its intestines or yeah it and it
blocked a part of his intestines he was
puking up feal mountain and [__] it was
and I was just going that the [__] out
of me and they couldn't figure out what
it was you know what I mean he had an
obstruction in his Jesus Christ just
from one tiny little hair like hair like
a metal hair from a grill brush isn't it
it wasn't he was at a barbecue at
somebody's house like his friend's house
or some [__] like that and I was just
kind of like oh my God a steak and he
ate it yeah like a steak or a burger or
something but it's just kind of like uh
yeah but some of the ones that diseases
too like people just like hey I was just
like walking through the woods or I was
just swimming in a lake one day or
something like that and then they come
down with these totally bizarre [__]
symptoms and because it's so unusual
like the doctors are just like yeah
never seen this [__] before this is
crazy guy worked with one of his little
boys he worked with him in in Louisiana
one of his little boys died of something
from a cut on his foot he was playing in
the butt yep and it got him and it
happen got infected and he started
getting real sick and they took him to
the hospital and they couldn't figure
out what was wrong with him and then by
the time blood work came back you know
they said he was just eaten up with some
of a bacteria yeah that was in um muddy
groundwater he was digging in a hole and
cut his there were a couple cases on
that show like that he did everything
they could he was only the boy was like
six yeah they did everything they could
cuz a lot of times like I said because
the shit's so unusual they don't think
of it you know what I mean it's not
really their fault they forgot what's
going on right you know they're just
human and it's like they little cut on
his ankle was infected they just go from
most likely to least likely you know
what I mean and sometimes it's too to
late which is kind of a shame but you
know I think I think they said it might
have been some kind of an amoeba or
something Amoeba's got in there like I
said I remember that happening yeah I
don't remember exactly something
microbi microbiology did it yeah it was
it was something unusual I think it
might have been an amiba of something
that got in
there Zach says I remember all the media
back in the 2000s about scenarios like
this and it always used to give me such
bad existential dread yeah I mean you
can't live your whole life worrying
about this kind of [__] because probably
it won't happen to you but I mean it
might it happened to these people yeah
during this time the intelligence
agencies and everything of the uh the
administration it didn't matter the
administration they're they're all the
[__] same um we're
using all the [__] fear they could to
try to get people to uh pass that uh
that uh [__] Patriot Act which
basically turned the United States into
a [__] police state it's still in
effect which they should have never done
that they that should have had a damn
down claws on it but it I don't know if
they'll ever be they have to get rid of
that that that [__] there it's too
tempting for them they can kill American
citizens with it if they just say you're
a terrorist yeah there's all kind of
crap there all kinds of [__] back
doors into there they can snoop and spy
on you without any [__] probable
cause if they think you're a
terrorist well how do you define
terrorist well whatever they can Define
terrorist as anything that they don't
like ex I mean any kind of vague
definition it's like well they're doing
[__] I don't like and in that case man
the [__] left was right they were
[__] they were warned everybody says
look man that you can't told [__]
yeah but now everybody was protesting it
doesn't matter though both sides will
use it they'll use it against each other
they'll use it against their enemies
it's too dangerous that's why a lot of
that shit's got to be dismantled that
that that RFK guy that that Kennedy guy
that's a good Democrat I [__] I like
that guy um everything he's telling you
people is true
you know that's what's happening at the
federal level it's all grift grift and
power and they're bad
people I mean although I feel like
that's been going on forever yeah
they're getting stronger and stronger
and stronger it's just as as as Empires
age they become more and more corrupt
more and more powerful the rot just sets
in that's why they don't last long an
Empire only lasts about 230 years 220
years usually before before something
goes
wrong Zach says this happened when I was
four oo wait a minute
that time yeah yeah I was yeah I was
grown too I knew I was going to get
called back into basic I was working cuz
I remember like I said when 9/11
happened I was at my job I was because
we watched it on the TV in the break
room me and all my [__] service
friends were getting ready to [__]
rub in our hands for all that damn
military defense Contracting Griff that
was going to come down we're going to
make all kinds of money in
[__] as [__] security contractors
and we did most of us ended up being in
in schools and in Training Camps
training
people yeah that should been on for a
long
time Danny says when 13 o'clock podcast
goes car shopping it would be awesome if
you guys filmed yourselves purchasing
your new car for Content just say we
might do that if I think about it no
probably I'm I'm probably gonna do a
um private purchase so I'm probably
going to buy from people who are sell I
don't want to go through dealers or car
lots you probably get a better deal I
mean and then I'll sell my car
separately yeah I will try it I'm going
to try to get the best deal I can I'm
looking for a couple different types of
cars um there's three Kia I'm looking at
and a couple of Fords I'm looking at
like I I'd go for
a Kia
Forte Soul or maybe a sarento if the
prices were right and I'd go for a a
Ford
Focus or a Ford Mustang I want the V6
though not a GT I just I don't need a
hot rod I just want a cool car uh I want
decent mileage I'm willing to put some
work in them too so you know I mean
because I can do work I'm [__]
qualified mechanic I can rebuild engines
if I want to
so there was even a damn [__] across
the street the guy selling like a
200,000 mile
[__] what is that thing I thought you
said it was a CR Vic no it's not better
than that it's a Mercury Grand Marquee
which is a loaded out it looks I think
it's older than my car though yeah my
car really old it looks really good all
leather interior it's a one of those old
boats and even that you can update them
and I know that car real
well those cars run forever the thing is
though I'm thinking do I want to drive
that [__] forever they're [__] huge
they don't get I would rather I would
rather have something small they don't
get great gas mileage but the parts here
in the United States are cheap for those
and high quality and it's like a tank
you know that's all your cop cars and
all all your old cop cars and your taxi
cabs and uh that's what
a that's what uh a Lincoln Town Car is
based
on I'd love to get a town car if I could
find a real town car and if it's in good
condition that's a limousine I mean
we're just going to lean into the old
person if you're going to be an old car
you [__] LOL Town Car they have huge
we're leaning into the elderly Vibe they
have huge air conditioning compressors
man they will blow [__] straight
blizzard you can set that thing on full
blast and it'll freeze you out of the
[__] car turn it down huge AC
compressors um and they don't get bad
gas mileage either well we don't drive a
great deal and it kind of for the money
that you kind of burn up in fuel you
save in repair costs because they don't
break off of they do break the parts are
cheap yeah that's the thing it's cheap
so that's the thing we're kind of like
like I said I'm letting Tom decide it's
his money yeah that he inherited uh and
he's going to be paying for the bulk of
it the pretty much the only contribution
I'm going to be making is whatever I get
for my car for my car and you know
helping to pay with for the insurance n
I'll probably let you keep that money
well you don't have to like I said
because I would be driving that car too
but but the thing is you've driven my
car for a long time and I've paid for
the insurance on that by myself for
years and years it'll be my don't put my
name on it my credit is not good I won't
have i't have to find it that I could
pay for it straight up yeah I'm looking
for something in the in the like between
I've seen some good deals at 4,000 but I
I can go as high as maybe seven eight
maybe yeah I think anything over that
would be a waste yeah because you can
get something really really decent yeah
here in Florida you for that amount Mone
that 6,000 area there's a lot to you can
get a lot of decent [__] for like six
7,000 and you can just pay for it
outright and not
and D insurance or anything yeah you can
just get lesser insurance going to
[__] pay for it all and [__] like
that I still have money left over I
could buy a motorcycle if I wanted to
yeah but I don't think I would I could
buy a [__] could buy a [__] used
Indian or used Harley with what's left
oh I got way behind in the comments
whoops um yeah Zach says uh by the way
Steve Mera got back to me on Facebook
and I'm sure I'm sure I'm doing his head
in with all my not knowledge about
parapsychology well yeah okay so did you
learn anything I mean we'll see all
right um let's
see yeah Camp guy is saying that um
maybe the amibe you were talking about
was called um naria
ferai the brain eating am yeah I think
that's what it was they said it attacked
his brain yeah they couldn't and they it
killed him quick like a week a week
later he was dead and they fought the
whole thing which that's kind of [__]
up like tell tell your loved ones that
you love them because you never know
when they're going to like drink a bad
bottle of water go get in the mud or
something like that and they'll be dead
a week later you don't know you know I
mean appreciate everybody while it's sad
you know when a little kid dies just
unexpectedly for something so stupid
just like a stupid just being a kid
playing in the [__] that's what I'm
telling you nature does not give a
single [__] it's not um malevolent but
neither is it benevolent it's just
indifferent yeah so got to watch your
ass out there but
even if you do watch your ass like I
said who would kind of think that you're
just like out farting around in the mud
one day and then a week later you're
dead so yeah but it does happen like I
said Universe don't care about you just
got to like enjoy your [__] time
while you're here make the best of [__]
I'm leaning towards um a a Kia Soul I
like I like that car I rented one and
drove it I liked it and a Ford Focus one
of those
too kiaforte looked good too but just
depends on what I can get a good deal on
yeah I mean you know we've been talking
about it a lot but like I said the
ultimate decision is going to be yours
mostly because one it's mostly your
money and two I'm not super picky like I
said all I really care about is I don't
really want a manual transmission I can
drive them but I would prefer not to um
and I just want something that's
reliable that's not going to break down
on me if I drive it somewhere by myself
this there's a lot of good deals on the
manual transmissions because I don't
really give a [__] what it looks like or
because they can't sell them to girls
and they're already modded they have
good wheels on them and [__] guys got
good exhausts on them and they're like
now they've been hot rotted that means
he's probably run a piss out of it but
which yeah I don't love that but but you
know I don't know we'll see yeah we'll
see how it goes like I said maybe we'll
film it if it's interesting but yeah I I
told Tom it's like maybe we should just
like film ourselves just doing regular
ass [__] because maybe people would like
that but I'm not really sure I'm not
really sure just like hanging out it's
like going to like today we went to
mimii yeah you know I took time to to
lunch today and then we went to then we
went to Publix and bought random [__] so
maybe people want to watch us do that I
don't really know yeah Camp guy said uh
my son was about 4 years old on 911
today his daughter is five and in
kindergarten yeah it seems I was going
to say it doesn't seem like that long
ago but it does seemed like that long
ago I mean when when 911 happened I was
at not my first first job but my first
big major graphic design job I had been
there for a couple of years um you know
I'd been married several years
so but it was a long time ago a long
time ago it seems like a long time
ago uh Mrs Evans Arty party is here we
had a 2014 focus and it was horrible
what was wrong with it yeah I'm not
really yeah I don't right if I got a
good deal on a on a V6 Mustang maybe
like the that 2005 I think it was 2005
to 200 what was it nine that first
revamped one I liked how that
looked the thing is is they're all kind
of high mileage but I had a Mustang an
sn95 Mustang that was high mileage and
rebuilt the motor because I bought it
with a [__] blown motor and that
[__] ran [__] he could just ran you
could run it into the ground but I just
got sick of driving a big heavy lad to
the ground [__] boat boat basically
what they feel like the old ones did
yeah I didn't love driving it like I
didn't mind it that much but it did seem
like super heavy
yeah Dom the bomb said I miss your post
Cinema reviews those were fun but we did
see a bunch of movies that I wouldn't
have watched otherwise sad said you guys
did the theater visit Vlog so you kind
of did it before yeah it's just I never
think about it I guess it's like but
maybe I should it's like content is
content right Zach says here's something
to make you feel old we have teenagers
learning to drive this year born the
year the first iPhone came out yeah I
mean I already feel old but thank you
thank you for that little thing Mrs
Evans Arty party said we have a 2016
Edge and we love it uh the focus had a
really weird transmission and it was
always in the shop for that everything
was so janky on that gu oh yeah that was
that that double double automatic
transmission yeah they said that there
was a class action lawsuit behind that
particular
one that was I think that was only
certain years
though Danny says live your life
cautious like Merill Streep's character
and Lemony snickets A Series of
Unfortunate Events movie I didn't see
the movie I read all the books though
the books are awesome but I I kept
meaning to get around to watching the
movies but I just never did but I love
the books they're
funny yeah she says everything broke one
after another on the focus and it was a
rough ride but really F but really fun
to drive I felt the same way like a long
time ago when I drove I think it was a
Chevy Cavalier holy crap you could just
tell from driving that around I'm like
wow this is really a piece of [__] yeah
the kiaforte is in the same class and
everybody seems to like that yeah
there's a lot of high mileage ones out
there we'll see how it goes and uh I saw
a mechanical review looked at the underc
carriage it's a simple car but it looks
like it's put together pretty well you
know for the money they you're get a lot
of car for your money but you get a lot
of I I have to go what they're offering
used on on on on Ford focuses man
they're they're there you get a lot of
for your money but like I said maybe
it's because they're having problems
yeah Al some people swear by them you
know I mean like I said we don't drive a
great deal um you know we just something
to go to the club back yeah we just go
to the club and back a couple times a
month you know go up the street to the
grocery store down to the down to the
Chinese buffet that's about the only
place we drive people seem to love the
Kia Soul very very few complaints in the
comment sections and uh they got them
out there [__] 300,000 miles you know
they done work on them but you know yeah
you got to kind of do work on yeah all
right so zanada just arrived so hi
zanada it seems a nice place to insert
that he has sent us yet another movie
which I have been wanting to see for a
very long time this movie right here
which is called come and see yeah and
that is the Criterion Edition yeah which
is a Russian Film like I said I've been
wanting to see this for a really long
time we will probably review this
because we still have to do The Departed
so we'll do that one CU he sent that one
too and we'll do that one on Monday and
then we'll do this one the following
Monday yeah because like I said I'm
really excited to see this I'm excited
to watch The Departed again too but I
have already seen that but I'm excited
for Tom to see it because I think he'll
really dig it all right so do you want
to get into
this yeah go ahead thing now all right I
mean we kind of talked about it at the
beginning so but then we kind of went
off on a thing cuz Tom's sitting there
going well how much how much uh material
do you have and I was just like well
that depends um on how many sidetracks
we go off on and he's like well do I
need to like add on to it cuz it's not
enough and I was just kind of like no
there's there's you show me how much
there is there's plenty but like I said
don't cuz I have my notes but it's like
don't always think about I mean
sometimes that's a good gauge of how
long it's going to be but not always
because sometimes some of the [__] I can
skip or it's not really that important
or whatever or if there's a paragraph I
can just like summarize that like in a
second or two because I can [__] if
I want to I'll pad that [__] out man I
can pad out of a show pad the [__] out
of a show well yeah everybody knows that
to you're very good at that yeah I mean
I'm guilty of it too because like some
especially if we get off on a topic that
I'm like really into like horror movies
or something I'll talk about that [__]
all night and then it's just like 6
hours long as like whoops probably
should have talked about the topic but
oh well but um that's why I like the
Sidetrack show so much cuz I don't have
to worry about I don't have to worry
about it although I do like I find all
this stuff interesting but I find all
the sidetracks interesting too but I
guess most of you guys to or do to or
you wouldn't be some people complain
about it not So Much Anymore um I don't
really chased all those off yeah I guess
like anybody that would have like whined
about that pissed off a long time ago so
you know what I mean like I I really
don't get that many negative comments
anymore so which I guess is good they
gave up I get yeah well really it was a
war of attrition it's just like look if
you don't like it part of it is when the
show is new there people are more
critical of you like they know like they
know how the show should
be but the show has been around for a
long time they just kind of shut the
[__] up no change in them people right
they've been around 10 years they must
be doing something right yeah I mean
it's not quite that long but yeah long a
lot of it had to do with the fact that
we just kept at it we just didn't give
up we forced we forced YouTube to deal
with us well and the thing is it's like
you know I could I could pretend to be a
certain way for not well not that long
actually no that thinking about it it's
G to come
out we can't pretend like I said we're
just being the way yeah we regularly are
this is literally no different than we
would be if you were here in the house
with us yeah guys I grew up with making
comment here and no is exactly I've
always been like this that's what I mean
we're just exactly our club friends you
know [__] exactly like David he'll
come in there and go yeah I see you guys
you know he hangs out with us he knows
how we are yeah I've known him forever
is exactly I think I've known him for
longer than I've known you actually now
that I'm thinking about probably this is
just how we do it yeah we're just we're
just acting the way we would normally
act and if people want to whine about it
then they can whine into the void
because I give not one single [__]
and I give less of a [__] the older I
get really that's good that's good
advice for anybody who has a YouTube
show who maybe had well they would know
by now if you want to make a YouTube
show just be yourself just do your own
[__] man yourself people who like it
will hang around people who don't will
[__] off yeah
win-win because you don't want those
people hanging around anyway whining at
you all day long you you should do it
like this and you should you should piss
off and mind your own [__] business
and make your own show if you know what
I mean they got this skinny goofy little
dude called review bro review bra oh
thank you very much Mrs Evans R thank
you very much got a Super Chat thank you
for a Super Chat we love that and uh if
you're listening to recorded we also
accept super thanks we respond to every
single one of them uh but no they got a
guy like who never would have been
noticed had he not just been himself and
that was that uh review bra yeah he's
just this skinny guy in a suit young guy
in a suit for a while he was living out
of his car I kind of love that guy
reviewing f
and he's just awkward as as [__] but
he's kind of like Mr Rogers he's very
endearing something mesmerizing about
his [__] behavior and obvious and
obviously he it struck a cord yeah CU
he's huge yeah CU he's got a massive
amount of followers yeah you know and he
just being
himself and he's like Unapologetic about
it and like I said he's not it's not
he's not playing a role he's not that's
what he's really like just weird dude
and he just started making videos and
people like responded to it you know
what I mean yeah that's kind of the best
way to go about it he tried something he
wasn't he never would have made it yeah
cuz if you try to be like you know look
at us giving advice like we're some
million subscribers or something which
we don't are you know 14,000 subscribers
I mean I don't know about that but um
but new people find us all the time
because I'm always getting messages it's
like oh my God I just found you guys you
know you got to search for certain
things to find us yeah but I mean the
thing about it is that there's so many
people and
one piece of I don't usually give advice
because I remember I had a professor a
long time ago and he gave a piece of
advice that said unsolicited advice
always blows up in your face yeah so
I've kind of kept to that to that tenant
um but I will say that it's always
better there's a lot of people out there
trying to do a popular thing oh yeah
like if somebody gets real big doing a
particular thing then there's going to
be a whole bunch of other channels
trying to do that same thing because is
like well that person got a million
subscribers so if I do this thing that's
similar then that but that's not how it
works though you know no you kind of
have to just do your own thing and hope
that you find yep an audience and hope
that you find a niche because you can't
be someone else and you're not going to
enjoy it anyway it's going to be just
like yep a slog you won't won't be you
will not be able to maintain that facade
no so you know like I said if people
don't like us just sitting here like
farting around and talking about a topic
most of the time but just then talking
about porn and food and cats and other
things yeah you know then oh well go
find another Channel I'm sure there's a
bajillion the the internet is vast you
can find other [__] that you like says
when he talks to me on over over
messenger voice because we we trade
voice messes he says I sound just like I
do on the show yeah well like I said I
just and people can believe me or not
but it's like I've known you for years
and years and years you're exactly the
same you're not putting on anything
you're this is exactly what he's like
yeah even when I'm sleeping he's exactly
like that even when he's
sleeping you're almost tell them what
happened last night oh my God so last
night I kept I had had one Roman coke
before bed okay we were just kind of
sitting there we were watching oh which
one of you guys recommended American
nightmare that [__] was [__] up we
watched that last night yeah on Netflix
um that was one of the craziest True
Crime things I've ever seen but yeah so
we were watching that and I said you
know what it's I don't usually but I was
like I'm going to get a drink drink I
just had one so I had like a Roman Coke
and so I was drinking so that whole
thing was predicated upon drinking ROM
and Coke for some reason makes me wake
up like a bajillion times at night
because I have to pee right so I had to
get up like three or four times so I
woke up at like
3:30ish something um to go to the
bathroom so I come back and get in bed
and Tom is
talking yeah and kind of thrashing
around which he used to do a lot you
haven't done that in a long time because
you used to have real bad um nightmares
yeah um but that's that was a long time
ago so he was but he was doing that
again he was kind of fighting and
talking to somebody and stuff I'm like
are you talking to me are you like awake
or whatever and then I get in bed and he
says I had a dream and for a second I
thought he was still asleep because I
said what did you dream about and he
didn't answer and then I was like what'
you dream about and he's like I dream
that all these people were coming in our
hotel room and I had to shoot them all
and I was like what people and he was
like Star Wars people yeah Star Wars
people Star Wars people yeah so all of
these people and he told me about the
dream like earlier today and I was just
like I fell back asleep all of his
dreams are like about fighting large
groups of people like he like he has to
kill them all I think the reason and I
told him I was like I think the reason
that you dreamed about people breaking
into our hotel room was because we had
watched American Nightmare before we
went to sleep which if you haven't seen
it it's a true crime miniseries it's
three episodes on Netflix about a real
thing that happened in California I
think back in 2015 I think it was um and
it was about a home invasion and ended
up being like about a serial rapist so I
think he was like thinking about that I
had a dream me and Jen were uh in
basically kind of like a love Motel type
of situation we were all scandy clad
[__] had like a bondage style canopy bed
and everything was there a heart-shaped
tub in the room please tell please tell
me there was I didn't see that okay
there's a party going on outside the
door so I opened up the door and I
looked out there and there was like a
whole nightclub out there and it was a
stage and there were two girls dressed
like those Twilights from
[__] Star Wars you know a red one and
a green one and the red one was [__]
stacked she's [__] dancing and all
the people are [__] watching and
they're all kind of like in Star Wars
outfits but it was kind of
fetish so I was okay yeah that's cool so
I I shut the door and walked away from
the door and the door door open open
back up and a girl came in and I went
and she was drinking she had a drink I
said no no no no I turned her ass around
I said this is our room get the [__] out
of here you know [__] ushed her back
out went to shut the door and the door
that's not like that's not like you Tom
normally like come on in no no no but
fck midd sh her back out no no no no you
were in the bed [__] talking to me I
shut the door as soon as I shut the door
I had my hand on the knob I felt the
knob twisting and the door pushing and
it wasn't that girl it was like several
people pushing and pushing and pushing
and I [__] locked it and just made it
but they broke the door open the door
went fly open I could just see a mass of
people and out of nowhere I already had
a [__] pistol felt like a [__] 40
or or 9 mm full service pistol so I just
let out a [__] cone of fire probably
let off around 30 shoo 10 12 rounds I
can hear him hitting you know I could
hear that what it sounds like when they
hit bodies you know kind of sounds like
a bubble going through the downn water
jug I know I'm hitting them but I can't
really make anything out I just see
Limbs and [__]
and I [__] woke up I was fighting
yeah like still coming yeah I couldn't I
couldn't shoot I was like on the edge of
the bed cuz he was like taking it was a
wave of them like a [__] something
out of the zombie movie didn't know
didn't matter how many of them I was
killing they were just coming in like a
[__] flood it's like [__] from
World War Z but they were they were
people and they were dressed like Star
Wars [__] people Star Wars people
yeah like [__] sand people he told me
he said Star Wars people and then like a
5 seconds later he was again yeah so he
just they dressed like [__] sad
people and the fu they dressed like the
dudes that were [__] in in one thing
Reb soldiers one thing I will note
though Rebel Alliance sh is that Tom one
of the details that you pointed out to
me in the dream was that um cuz he told
me about the stream earlier today and he
was just kind of like yeah we were in
this motel and it's like we were scandy
clad he said so we must have just been
[__] that's what he said and like a
love Motel right and so but then later
in the dream he says I pulled the pistol
out of my waistband yeah and I'm like I
know did you not have a waistband or did
or did you have like your your gay
panties on doesn't make any sense it's
in a dream a [__] weapon it could
have been a I call them his gay when I
need it when I need something I it could
be a flamethrower could have appeared in
my hands in in the middle of a dream I
could have been in a g string one minute
having a flamethrower the next it
doesn't make any sense well I mean
technically those um what are those
manties that you have what are they what
do they say on them jockmail yeah
jockmail
yeah his manties why is she talking
about my underwear well because I was
like had you had those on yeah then yeah
technically you could have had a pistol
that's kind of what I was imagining no I
was I pulled it out back my waist
especially the pair that you have that's
like a jock strap I kind of imagining I
[__] I instantly had I was imagining
I instantly had clothes on I had pants
on oh okay you know I had pants on and a
belt and everything s's pistol
yeah and you're just like I'm going to
[__] up all these Star Wars people I
just yeah it happened fast I thought
that was funny a wave of Star Wars
people tried to come in I didn't have
any it's I guess because I'm used to
watching True Crime [__] and it's just
like I don't I don't want to say I'm
desensitized to it because I'm not but I
don't usually have nightmare well
sometimes I do but I not about the one
we saw last night although the one we
saw last night was like super disturbing
just because it was so [__] weird
that was one of the weirdest [__]
cases I've ever heard of super [__]
weird like watch it it's good
you will
um and I've and I've seen like and read
about a lot of Weird True Crime cases
but that one went in uh directions I did
not expect let's say that um so uh
murder Hornet keeps telling you to look
at messenger yeah man he come on he's
busy no I'm just kidding I'm working
dude Tammy says people want to have an
orgy with you Tom maybe that's what it
is they're just very very aggressive
about they're very aggressive about it
they're very aggressive about it we do
get people like I don't know what people
just want to have threes Sims with us I
don't know what it is that's that's gone
on for a long time they're not like
trying to break into the hotel room to
the extent where they get shot but I got
I got sidetracked I was listening to
what he said no I said for a long time
like people always seem to want to have
threes Sims with us yeah and forom yeah
but and my ex-girlfriends yeah it's a
whole thing and they and their husbands
it's a whole thing but um like I said as
far as I know they're not breaking into
our breaking into our house or anything
yeah so you
know okay so I guess we should probably
start talking about this now I mean we
haven't been going we haven't been
yapping too long no no we're warmed up
everybody we're kind of warmed up like I
said I did pregame slightly not well I
drank like a little bit we're drinking
Ramen coke before the show started I had
a [__] stiff one man stiff stiff one
sound like a damn like I had a stiffy
yeah you did have a stiff one no this
strong man hopefully I'll be able to
make it you'll be all right I'm still
only on my first first one but this is
also very strong yeah because when I
make it's probably a mistake when I make
my own drinks cuz I'm just kind of like
I pour the liquor in there first and I'm
just kind of like that's not enough and
then I put ice in and then I put soda in
then I'm just like that was probably too
much oh well that's Mardi I'll sort it
out it'll be it'll be all right but I
like to like loosen up a little bit so
yeah um so okay so probably like I said
we went a little bit into this proa
anyone that was alive at this time
period and you know I can't really um
you know say that across the board
because obviously Zach was only four
when this happened it's [__]
hilarious so that's so crazy to think
about that's hilarious so like I said
yeah pretty much like everybody was that
was alive and sentient at the time that
9/11 happened like remembers that just
like I not only remember that I remember
vividly when the [__] when that
shuttle exploded in 1986 yeah I remember
that too um and that was
1986 1986 I think I was in seventh grade
e8th grade something like that space
shuttle was the dumbest thing ever well
dumb you know dumb design they don't do
it anymore yeah it was cool at the time
I used to go and see the launches all
the time but that was like yeah that was
super upsetting so um so yeah so I
remember that and I remember 2011 but I
remember the [__] hype that happened
after this and I understand why
everybody thought it was related because
whoever did it whether it was Dr Ivans
who we're going to talk about in a bit
whether it was really him or not um
whoever did it seemed to at least on a
surface level want people to believe
that it was connected you know what I
mean now the case as far as I'm aware
from what I could glean from the
research that I did the case is I guess
closed because the FBI determined well
Dr Ivans was the guy that did it um he
acted
alone and therefore you know it's over
like we don't really have to look for
anybody else there is still some
controversy about that over whether that
dude did did actually do it or not but I
don't know like I said the evidence
against him is circumstantial but there
is a lot of circumstantial evidence so
we'll get into that in a bit I'm not
really sure if I can
go right to the point where I was like
oh yeah that [__] totally did it but I
mean it does kind of seem I'm probably
like 85% I think he did it you know what
I mean and he probably acted alone
because he seemed kind of like a nut so
I'm just going to
say so as I mentioned um Anthrax is a
naturally occurring compound it can go
in you like lots of different it can
kind of like go through your skin you
can breathe it in [__] like that as far
as I know um the pulmonary or
inhalational version which is like the
spores and stuff I think that is the
most deadly and as I mentioned before
that is I believe between 80 and 90%
fatal uh when you get that but it does
occur in nature but it's very very rare
you can get it from contaminated meat
like from cows and stuff you can get it
from dirt you can get it from different
places but it's very unusual before this
attack the last person in the United
States that had died of anthrax was in
1976 and I believe that that was
naturally uh that they had got that
naturally like it wasn't uh terrorism
obviously so here's what happens so
after the terror attacks happened on 911
2001 a week later on September
18th there are five letters containing
Anthrax
spores that were sent from a mailbox
they were all sent from the same mailbox
uh they later determined it was in
Trenton New
Jersey now it took you know a few days
obviously for these letters to turn up
where they were sent now the letters
were addressed to the New York Post one
was addressed to the National Inquirer
one was addressed to ABC uh one was
addressed to CBS one was addressed to
NBC um now when they first arrived at
these places no
one thought anything unusual about it
because they get you know thousands of
letters all the time and it's just kind
of like so they didn't really think
anything was weird uh you know they just
got these weird letters and they're just
like okay what whatever now one of them
was specifically addressed to Tom
broka now his he didn't open it but um
you know because they have interns for
that the woman that did open it whose
name was Casey Chamberlain uh and she
was his
assistant now she said the only thing
she commented was she's like well the
letter looked like a kid had written it
because if you see the letters they're
like block you know block letters and
they're like photocopied and stuff um
and she's like they seemed weird but you
know and there was a a weird substance
in there but she didn't know what it was
um she said it kind of looked like Brown
Sugar Sand and brown sugar s sand and
brown sugar like mixed together like she
didn't know what it was and she was just
like okay whatever like I said that's
probably what most people would think
you wouldn't think this is a deadly
pathogen thankfully she did not um get
sick some people did not that handled it
but you know what I mean now it so
happened that on October 4th there was a
guy named Robert Stevens now he actually
worked at the national Inquirer as like
a photo editor and he had handled one of
these letters as well that came to the
National Inquirer and he was actually
hospitalized and he was the first person
to be diagnosed with inhalation
Anthrax now at this stage because you
know there hadn't been a pattern
established yet yet
obviously um you know authorities were
just kind of like oh well they didn't
connect it with the letter that came
into the national Inquirer because like
I said why would
you and they were just like well he must
have got it naturally somehow like I
said he must have got it from the soil
or he's been hanging around a cow that
had Anthrax or something so they didn't
really think about it um and really as I
said because these letters were kind of
spread out and they didn't really so
they didn't really like connect them at
first like I said it seems in hindsight
it seems like they should have but I can
understand why that didn't
happen um you know so basically like
Casey Chamberlain the um the woman that
opened the Tom broa Letter she did kind
of get sick from the anthrax but she
didn't die from it thankfully um she did
actually go to the doctor to report her
symptoms but because they you know
Anthrax is so rare they didn't think of
that they just thought oh well maybe
she's having a reaction to some
medication she was taking or something
like that
um another one of Tom Broca's assistants
also got sick around this time but again
they didn't really diagnose that as
Anthrax because it wasn't really utmost
in anyone's mind now the day after
Robert Stevens went to the hospital he
was the guy that worked at the national
inquir um he actually died so he was the
first Anthrax
death now 4 days later or three or four
days later on October 9th there were two
more letters that had these Anthrax
spores in them and they were mailed
again from the same mailbox in Trenton
New Jersey now this time um the letters
were addressed to two Democratic
senators one of them was Tom dashel uh
from South Dakota and one of them was
Patrick lehy who was from
Vermont um now at this point in time um
Tom dashel was the Senate Majority
Leader and Patrick Ley was the chairman
of the Senate Judiciary
Committee now the letter that was
addressed to Senator dashel um obviously
he didn't open it they have assistance
and stuff like that uh for that now that
letter was opened by one of his interns
on October 15th uh whose name was Grant
Leslie now at this I guess at this point
they kind of had heard about the other
letters so they were kind of a little
bit more on alert
so basically the intern opened the
letter and was like oh my God what the
[__] is in here and you know alerted the
authorities so they actually immediately
like closed down the House and Senate
buildings so and Clos them for
decontamination because by this time
they had determined this is a pathogen
we need to like do something about it um
now the letter that had been addressed
to Patrick lehy they um didn't actually
find that one until about a month later
because it turned out that somebody at
the Postal Service had misread the ZIP
code so it got sent to a different place
it got sent to um like a mail Annex like
at the state department it was just like
in this Barrel like along with a bunch
of other ones but they did eventually
find
it now the letters both of the letters
that have been addressed to the Senators
they had a fictional return address on
them one of them had passed through the
Hamilton Township postal facility and
one the Brentwood postal facility
so the day after the dashel letter was
found there was a worker at the Hamilton
Township facility that was that tested
positive for cutaneous Anthrax which is
the kind that goes through your skin um
which is bad but less lethal you know
what I mean although I think in this
case although I can't remember like if
this was the person that died or not cuz
a couple of them did um another
worker um got sick on October 17th now
they closed the Hamilton facility down
on October 18th because they wanted to
test everything for Anthrax and kind of
like try to decontaminate it but the
Brentwood facility stayed open um even
though two workers there Thomas Morris
Jr and Joseph Kine um started to get
sick now on the documentary that they
had on Netflix relatives of those two
men are still pretty mad about it which
you know
um understandably because they were like
well look they closed the Senate and
House buildings they closed this other
postal facility but this one they just
kept making us still come to work even
though they knew there was [__]
Anthrax in there like what is that
[__] and then two guys ended up
dying spoiler alert now the letters that
had um the letters from the first batch
not the ones that had been sent to the
Senators but the ones that had been sent
like to the
media um had these letters in them that
were written like in block letters so
one of them says
91101 this is next take penicillin which
was spelled wrong take penicillin now
death to America death to Israel Allah
is great that's what the first one said
and then the letters to the Senators
said
91101 you cannot stop us we have this
Anthrax we got this Anthrax right here
um you die now are you afraid death to
America death to Israel Allah is great
so that's what that one said and like I
said you've in broken English yeah
that's what they were I was like nice
try bro but okay yeah um they can get a
hold of Anthrax but they can't they
don't speak fluent English the kind of
dude that can get a hold of Anthrax as a
[__] PhD that's what it's going to
take well as we'll see that's likely
what happened yeah he's got a PhD that
he he can Harvest it and [__] process
it and [__] or at least has so or if he
has access to that kind of [__]
technology he's got access to somebody
who can write a badass letter and if
you're going to [__] launch that [__]
it's going to be a detailed letter
probably it's going to be all [__]
eloquent and it's probably going to have
something to do with Israel occupying
the [__] you know yeah You' think
they would have like demands yeah
there'd be all kinds of [__] you know
what I mean there would say people can
speak speak fluent English in other
parts of the world it doesn't sound like
it doesn't sound like an old western
where they had like Indians in there
going yeah how how you do this you know
what I mean that's kind of what this
letter sounds like to you're
sophisticated enough to get your hands
on Anthrax you're sophisticated enough
to write write a badass letter I know
this is a weird thing to say but this
was some good Anthrax as in the way that
it was administered and the way that um
was like only a handful of people on
earth like knew how to do that yeah if
you can get your hands on that then that
means you can get your hands on somebody
who can write a badass letter in English
it's going to be yeah that doesn't
highend operation it's not going to be
some [__] something that a couple of
dudes wearing flipflops out in the
middle of [__] Afghanistan with a 75
IQ no those that's not the guys who are
doing it it's going to be somebody with
PhD yeah access to PhD we have this phds
you now yeah guys with phds are on the
team you know so so you know kind of so
and they're going to maximize the yield
out of this mission so they're going to
make all kinds of Demands it's the
shit's going to be [__] very
intricate and it's going to be real
persuasive too that's why I think even
though there are still lingering
theories that maybe this was some kind
of like thing that was connected to 911
was connected to Al-Qaeda I'm not sure I
entirely buy it because like I one they
didn't have any
demands um it just seemed like you know
I and maybe this is a weird thing to say
because you know
sadly like five people are dead and like
a bunch of other people got infected but
it seemed like halfast it didn't really
seem like right it's terrorism in the
sense that you're trying to strike fear
in random people just the same way that
whoever the [__] did the Chicago Chicago
Tylenol thing did which I don't think
they ever caught that [__] but
um I mean they kind of think they know
who it is but they couldn't prove it um
but this it just seemed like if it was
the dude that they thought it was Dr
Ivans um that dude had some other
motives and some other issues yeah you
know what I mean it just doesn't it
doesn't add up you got a high-end weapon
and a low-end letter nah
yeah
no that's not gonna happen San said this
is starting to sound a lot like Ted
kazinski yeah I mean similar but Taz
kazin's letters were the [__] well
they were eloquent yeah and he was like
he was he was a nut but I mean he had
like philosophical [__] like to back up
all of he was he was n but he wasn't
wrong per se that's what I mean well
like I said you know that just because
you have mental problems doesn't mean
you're not right about them yeah I don't
think kazinski was crazy though I think
he was I think he was Disturbed but not
crazy he was well I'm just using that as
kind he he thought that these
corporations were taking over the earth
a lot of the things that he worried
about yeah they're doing and he was
really worried about uh [__] what he
call transhumanism and the fact that
they would eventually corporations would
eventually learn how to make humans as a
product a biological product that they
would sell uh which is like something
out of Blade Runner and and you know and
[__] uh guy who wrote that [__] he
he he kind of believed the same things
that that was because that's really the
direction it was evolving too and that's
kind of what what they what they want
now they want to do lab grown meat you
know I'd eat lab grown meat if it was
cheap and it tasted good I if it tasted
the same then I don't really have a
problem with it because it's like hey
you don't have to kill animals that's a
win yeah you just but the thing is this
going to have to be a bargain and I
don't want it all going to [__] Ted
what's his name [__] Bill Gates I
don't [__] like that dude he he'd
want to [__] set up a monopoly I want
four or five competing companies making
that well the thing about it is that
once somebody figures out a good way to
do it then everybody's going to be able
to do it so there's going to be little
startup companies and [__] like that
yeah but the thing is once you can make
[__] lab grown meat you can make lab
grown human beings why would you want to
we have plenty of those well
the idea is to make Superior human
beings yeah I know so now you're talking
about [__] what's his name [__]
con Nunan sing and [__] [__] starw
workk yeah or something like out of GAA
but um that's right which that may not
be a bad thing but as soon as you start
making guys at that level and women at
that level they don't see you as human
beings they see you as the way a human
would see a chimp CU they're the next
step in human evolution just give me a
payoff and I'll just be over here being
a chimp yeah just enough to but they
wouldn't pay you off they'd kill you
well probably which is that was the
problem in Star Trek story I finally got
that [__] hair got it out there good
yeah it's been bugging me like the whole
time it was like stuck behind my glasses
yeah um yeah let's see uh Victor says
the anthrax was traced back to Texas
A&M's lab and the original sample was
sent in for testing from a veterinarian
in my hometown Dr Vickers that's pretty
cool Zan said you guys should do the
Japanese cult that did the sarin attack
sometime yeah I've been wanting to do
talk about yeah I mean did we cover that
no we talked about doing it we me we
mentioned them on on a show yeah but we
didn't we didn't make a whole show about
it yeah I don't think we did the
Japanese Jesus Japanese
Jesus anytime somebody comes forward and
says they're Jesus that's a red flag you
just back away slowly yeah and when he
wants you to relief ner nerve agent in
the [__] subway station you know that
ain't I mean way before you get to that
point you should have noted out yeah
should have noed out way before it got
to that stage but Cults man I'm
fascinated by how they work like I said
anybody can be sucked into a cult I like
to think that I would never get sucked
into one just because I'm so cynical and
I don't like people and I'm not a joiner
and anybody that would ask me to like
join a group of anything I'm just like
no thank you but you know I don't know
they always take your best intentions
and use them against you that's what
it's all about well I don't have any I
don't have any best intentions so you
know that's that's how I keep my ass if
you're not very altruistic and I mean I
am altruistic but I'm also super lazy
all you got to do is just look right at
[__] Scientology if you ask us ex
scios why did you join well I wanted to
help I wanted to help people I wanted to
help the Earth get the [__] out of here
I want to save the planet get the [__]
out of here as soon as somebody says
like like you have the right or the
ability to save the [__] planet
planet doesn't want you're saving well
the thing is Christian trying to save
all these people look if you want to
make [__] better I don't know just go
pick up trash on the side of the highway
or something like or give money to a bum
or something like that like just do
something small scale like if more
people did that like you it doesn't that
way well no I'm just saying that you as
one person can't save the world you just
can't it always boils down to the same
thing when they're saying they're trying
to save the Earth it always ends up
being I will save the Earth if you put
me in charge yeah and we and we want
everybody particular and then I [__]
kill off the people who are bad so we
only have good people that's what
mustach man was doing same thing yeah
it's a red flag like it's a red flag
when they say we're we're going to save
Everybody by getting rid of all the
evildoers yeah because they're like well
save every save everybody that we like
is what that means is what that means
you know where I'm perfectly willing to
tolerate people I don't like as long as
they don't [__] with my [__] you know
what I mean it's fine just don't get up
in my face about it that's all and we'll
all just get along or not we just won't
talk to each other but just don't [__]
with each other that's all it's easy
just mind your own [__] business
that's really all you have to do just
mind your own [__] business so okay
so as this went on as far as they know
I'm sure it was probably more CU maybe
some people got infected and they didn't
go to the hospital or whatever but as
far as they know um 22 people were
infected with Anthrax and five people
died um out of the 22 people that were
infected 12 of them were postal workers
because that was just [__] that was just
coming through the facility and people
got like I said none of the people that
the letters were targeted to none of
those people got you know got Anthrax it
was always like the the kind of
Frontline people like you know the
interns or the postal workers or
whatever you know the the people down
here the little people that always get
kind of [__] over so there was that
also there was a baby who was 7 months
old who was actually the son of somebody
that worked at ABC news they were like a
producer or something and the baby got
Anthrax like was infected with Anthrax
just after visiting the building like
for take your kid to workday or whatever
um the kid didn't die thankfully but um
you know so that's how Insidious this
[__] is you can just go to the building
that the letter was in and you know and
you get it so they did have other than
the 22 people that were infected there
were also 31 other people that tested
positive for exposure to the anthrax
bores um and as far as they know there
were about another 10,000 people that
they thought may have been exposed so
they gave them antibiotics just in case
you know what I mean um so there were
about
35 like post offices mail room
facilities stuff like that that had to
be
decontaminated um there were 26
buildings on Capitol Hill that they
tested um out of those seven of those
buildings had uh contaminant in there so
had to be kind of closed down for a time
I remember a lot of stuff being closed
at that because they were trying to like
clean all the [__] out they also had a
quarantine like a whole bunch of mail
and [__] like that um you know so uh as
I said five people died Robert Stevens
was the first one he was the guy that
worked for National inquire he was the
first one that died um Thomas Morris Jr
and Joseph Kine were both postal workers
they also passed away um on October 21st
and October 22nd uh the fourth person
this was a little bit weird the fourth
person fourth person who died was um she
actually got uh the pulmonary the
inhalational uh anthrax was um Kathy uh
how do you pronounce that Vietnamese
last name I think it's nen or or
something like that n n ye n new I think
it's Newan I think or something like
that cuz I know I've seen other people
pronounce that name and it's not how you
think it's pronounced so she was
actually 61 years old um she had
immigrated here from uh Vietnam many
years ago and she worked at a hospital
at the Manhattan eye ear and throat
hospital now she got Anthrax they
couldn't quite figure out how she got it
because she wasn't in the media she was
didn't work in any of the offices where
the letters came in and she wasn't a
postal worker but when they had another
woman die um who was a 9 four-year-old
woman named um Odie lungren they figured
out that she got it she was also
unrelated hey Pokey she was also
unrelated to the media or you know she
didn't work in the post office or
anything like that um they think that
because the anthrax letters had gone
through the postal facility that also
delivered her mail that it contaminated
her mail so she might have got it from
that so like I said it just kind of
[__] spreads you know what I mean and
people died from that as little
particles it just gets everywhere that's
what I mean it spores and that's why
everyone's so [__] terrified of it
because it can spread super easily like
I said people that weren't even in the
vicinity or weren't even there when the
letter arrived or anything like that
gets in your lungs you breathe it in it
starts growing in there [__] you and
it's super yeah yeah it it's super uh
fatal that's why like I said a lot of
people are like freaking out about it
because you know people that weren't
even in the [__] buildings and [__]
got this ass best is evil twin
brother that's what I'm saying imagine
if asbest could
grow yeah it's [__] up well like I
said there could be [__] Anthrax in
here right now I don't know coming
through the mail I don't
know so because people are the worst um
when this whole Anthrax thing started of
course there were a bunch of chuckle
[__] out there in the US who thought it
would be hilarious to do like hoaxes and
stuff so they're sending letters to
their friends with like white powder in
there o it's Anthrax yeah super funny
super funny um that they know of there
were
15,000 hoaxes reported during this time
period
15,000 and I'm sure that there were more
than that that weren't reported so like
I said cut it out people do better don't
[__] do that it's not funny so yeah
now because of all of these hoaxes and
fals like everybody was freaking out
like I said this was literally a month
after 911 so everyone was a little bit
sensitive as you can imagine um so all
of this crap happening and then all of
these hoaxes happening everybody was
like losing their [__] right I remember
it so because of that um the CDC and
everything like that they were just like
they had to test everything because like
we don't know like some of them could be
legit so they had to like set up this
whole triage system and [__] like that
and it was just like a whole cluster F
now it so happened one of the biggest
perpetrators of this cuz we want to name
and shame the people that do this kind
of [__] um one of the biggest hoaxes was
this dude named Clayton Lee Wagner
Wagner with two A's at the beginning now
this Chad was already he already had a
very long history of harassing abortion
clinics history of Chism yeah a history
of Chism of assholery and Dick Hy and
general chicanery so yeah so he had a
long history of um cuz he was like real
Fundamentalist and stuff and uh so he
had been harassing um women's clinics
abortion clinics for like a really long
time and when the anthrax attacks
happened he was like ooh what a good
idea so he started sending letters to
abortion clinics that had white powder
in them um you know he would put stuff
on the envelope that said time sensitive
information like open immediately blah
blah and then it would have all this um
yeah and it had all this powder in it
but it's like they had to check
everything because they weren't sure and
they didn't know where the stuff was
going and then also the letters would
have death threats in them so that's
nice yeah so he sent a bunch of those um
and it's kind of funny because like a
lot of the abortion clinics or stuff
like the people that work there are like
yeah we get this [__] all the time even
before the anthrax [__] happened it's
like so they were I'm I'm not saying
that they weren't scared because they
were but it's just kind of like yeah
we've been getting death threats for
like forever so we're kind of inor to it
a little bit at this point the abortion
clinics dudes I had
I I'd like to [__] find out more
about them do some [__] cycle
analysis operation rescue yeah like
let's do a show about them are they
really that altruistic that they're
trying to save other people's kids no I
wouldn't think so no because I'm like
well wait aren't you a Christian he says
well yeah well don't you want
non-Christian people don't you want
their numbers to dwindle they should be
having as many abortions as possible and
you if you're a Christian should have
many children as possible in a few
Generations you'll outnumber them
they're not good at math though those
but they can't but that's not what it is
they I'm just making a joke well yeah as
you listen to Islam they are telling
everybody have as many children as you
can so we can outnumber the
non-believers that so they they embrac
that and if they're if and they're not
attacking abortion clinics they like no
no no they should have as many abortion
we should build abortion clinics that's
the way is Islam would approach it well
I think that the the crazy people that
pick it in front of abortion clinics for
example um I think those people are
maybe well one they're nuts so it's kind
of like kind of hard to discern their
motives EXA they want to be important
they want to be seen to be doing
something that looks like they're trying
to impress their friends how good they
are yeah um and also I think maybe they
think oh well if people have these
babies we can convert them to
Christianity I think that's maybe but
but I think that's like way in the back
of their mind they're not thinking that
way I don't think they probably are
no and and here's another possibility
that they are just shitty shitty people
that don't have anything better to do
there's also that so I don't know I mean
that's kind of that's kind of what I
think I think it should be avoided I
mean know you know but the thing is is
that it should also be avoided that
people that don't want children
shouldn't be having them yeah you know
you want to avoid that too because you
can look at the problems what happens
when you have a bunch of unwanted
children running around they end up
having [__] being serial killers and
[__] criminals so yeah [__] you
nip that [__] in the bud don't let the
CH don't let the parents have children
you know so I can understand that that
solves a lot of problems you know well
look now some of this shit's kind of
weird they're saying they're selling
that fetal material or pulling them kids
out of their live and keeping them alive
that does not happen let them grow so
they can get some that is a fear that
some of them have that does not happen
you might be able to do that though that
does not happen technology might
exist that doesn't mean it happens
though that doesn't that that does not
happen if it was real late term it would
probably
live we're not not even getting into
that because I all of that [__] all of
that [__] is scare mongering that's all
that is they just make up a bunch of
crazy [__] stories to get their base
all excited about it and get them all
outraged that's just what they do they
make up a bunch of [__] that absolutely
never ever happens
never even if it may be happened one
time like under some other context or
something like that they will blow that
[__] out of proportion because they want
everybody they want them all to get mad
they want them all to get outraged how
they fire them up China has no issues
with any of this you know abortion they
they they like all that selling human
body parts harvesting human parts out of
people that are in prison um I'm sure
they had no problem with genetic
engineering and and uh making designer
babies there's probably a lot of that
has already happened but if it has
happened it it would probably be in
China because they don't have any
problems with it uh but I would like to
see actually know what the state of the
technology is it's
probably ahead of what what we're being
told like um I know they can
clone uh with the old technology and
this is [__] decades ago now what 340
years ago they were cloning sheep I'm
now sometimes there were problems with a
sheep they didn't live that long but a
lot of that had to do that they were
just kind of sucking DNA out of a damn
cell and then blowing it back into
another set and getting them to divide
and making multiple sheet now it wasn't
perfect you'd have to make like 40 or 50
of them and most of them wouldn't take
you might only have like two or three
tank out of a batch of
50 and then they were exact
duplicates but I would imagine that with
today's technology is you could probably
what would happen is when they pulled
that DNA DNA out of there would break
and it could break again when it went
back in into the new
cell so the copies weren't real
perfect but you got the the copies that
were the best he actually would bear
fruit you know and things that be born
but I would imagine with today's
technology you could probably get it
pretty foolproof with like you know some
of these little tiny [__] nano
technology that they have now but
interesting to know how how far along
cloning and genetic engineering really
is China would know and it would
probably be secret I would think it
probably wouldn't let it out
DVD Dragon says Florida man is the next
step in human evolution off the Sun and
bath salts can summon a hurricane of
gators at a moment's notice to deal with
anyone's [__] yeah yeah why why have
they made like gator
NATO that'll be one Florida is the Nexus
man it's the place where everything
[__] com combines and it creates
things like Florida man there's Florida
Gator I got him on video biting a dude
it was [__] great I shared it with
some of my friends on I didn't blame the
gator in that situation because the dude
looked like hey I'm going to go in a
ditch and [__] with this alligator I'm
like well yeah [__] around and find out
yeah he [__] around and he found out
that he tried to put a towel on that
alligator's head it [__] him up and
his buddy [__] was recording
it some people were like's recording and
not helping which I kind of thought was
awesome yeah like who's he's just like
oh well that's all on you buddy he's
very wi A very wise man I'm just GNA
stand back here and film it record
recorded by a very probably what I would
do too because like look if I was with
some [__] friend of mine hey I'm
gonna go over here and [__] with this
alligator I'm like all right I'm just
going to stand way back here yeah and
he's in his 60s this is not a young guy
you get eaten I'm just going to this is
a dude in his 60s he was old enough to
know better old enough to know better he
didn't die I don't think no he got away
from it he got away that thing [__]
grabbed him and shook
him that is a wild animal you were
[__] with him I'm not [__] with a
wild animal especially not a [__] Al
alligator yeah they're strong it's just
a short burst of power lots of strength
they will just grab you and drag you
underwater and you will drown yeah they
get tired quick but for a few seconds
they're [__] amazingly strong it's
like yeah oh you look like such a badass
now getting dragged Under Water by an
alligator yeah good job taking him out
of the gene pool although he probably
already reproduced sadly I couldn't
imagine that dude being from
Florida I think that was somebody who
moved here that had balls well see
thought he could do that I don't know
he didn't know how to catch an alligator
for the rule number one never try to
catch an alligator that's longer than
three feet
long good actually just don't try to
catch an alligator or a snake or
anything in Florida I once period once
on the show I was said I'm going to
[__] do a video I'm g go down and you
going record me I'm G grab I'm going
catch one of these
alligators and I'm pretty I'm pretty
confident I can I could probably catch
one about 4 feet long pretty confident
pretty confident yeah I how it's done
I'm just going to stand back here and
film it yeah I'm not going to help you
if something yeah jump on his back and
grab his [__] mouth and hold it
closed because you because somebody come
and tape his mouth shut because actions
have consequences actions have consequen
and those [__] Tails back there
fighting and then you know but what I'm
G to do with him you know I'm not gonna
do anything with him I'm just gonna let
him go just get a video of it and
honestly like I don't really understand
like other than ooh look how badass I am
um why would you [__] with a wild animal
leave them alone they didn't not do
anything back in the day back in the day
we were catching them and killing them
to eat them I mean that's something else
like if you're going to eat it okay yeah
but if you're just [__] with it cuz
it's just like look I can [__] with an
alligator like look I'm a badass it's
just like piss off with that we didn't
catch him alive though we just shot him
you're just a dumbass and I hope he eats
you we just shot him with a 37 Magnum
pistol you [__] go up to him with a
[__] Robbo and they'll submerge just
throw some fish out after a while when
he calms out he'll come back up and just
[__] shoot him pow and then go over
there and get him and put him in a boat
like I said that's a different thing if
you're just killing it to eat it yeah I
don't like well I don't like show offy
people anyway but it's just kind of like
somebody that's like show offy like that
I'm like yeah I just hope you get eaten
or at least get your arm bitten off so
you live to regret it that would
actually probably be better in
Mississippi it was legal to Spotlight at
night for alligator for Gator and
[__] frog so you could just spot like
the lake and if you saw glowing eyes you
go there's alligator you go over there
and you use right and shoot him from the
bank but then you take a boat out there
and go get him yeah you don't go there
and wrestle the [__] no in wrestling why
would you do that yeah and the only
thing is edible is the tail the tail and
the back legs have some meat on them and
it's it's it's an acquired taste uh I
think it's pretty good they're actually
I I think it can be kind of dry and
fishy tasting sometimes but I don't mind
that I like fish so I've had alligator a
few times I wouldn't choose it but it's
it's good it's good alligator sauce
peon yeah I mean like I said I wouldn't
go out of my way to order it but if
somebody offered me some and it was free
and I'd be like alligator tof it's
pretty good yeah it's pretty good yeah
Zan said kodo dragon is cooler than an
alligator I'm just saying yeah I mean in
some ways probably yeah the thing is you
don't want to eat those those are
[__] nasty they car Le you can't eat
an alligator just like you can eat an
alligator yeah not the whole thing but
you know what I mean yeah Z said I had a
deep fried Gator at the Minnesota State
Fair was good yeah I mean deep fried
anything is pretty good not going to lie
it's kind of like it's kind of like
turtle or fish yeah I've only had turtle
one time yeah yeah they're all just kind
of like fishy tasting which that's okay
with me cuz I like seafood but some
people do not if you don't like seafood
then you probably won't like turtle or
alligator either because that's kind of
what they taste
like all right so where were we so yeah
so we were talking about like these dumb
asses that did all these hoaxes and
stuff and I'm just like like I don't get
that this is kind of the same thing
because every time there's a big um like
True Crime case that goes National like
you know johnin ramsy or something like
that there's always a small percentage
of [__] that will call him and
go yeah I did that [__] I don't
understand that psychology but okay
there's always some people out there
willing to do that I don't get it so and
the same thing about
hoaxing Anthrax everybody's sending
Anthrax to each other hilarious so yeah
now in
October uh mid October October
13th as I said at the beginning people
were kind of initially thinking maybe
this is probably related to 911 somehow
right because it seems like a biot
terrorism
attack however uh on October 13th there
were um a bunch of microbiologists at a
particular lab uh Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory to be specific and
they found out that the anthrax strain
that was in all of these letters was the
Ames strain now this is a strain of
Anthrax that was um that actually the US
Army had acquired in
1981 initially it came from a diseased
cow in Texas and then they kind of you
know built different cultures off it and
stuff like
that now at this point like a lot of the
scientists are kind of freaking out
because they were like well this means
that whoever did this is probably an
American and probably somebody that
works with Anthrax right um and probably
not a middle eastern terrorist as they
were trying to kind of push at the time
um and the thing about the aim strain in
particular was that they knew it was a
particularly um virulent strain um and
that vaccines weren't all that effective
against it uh they had been working on
it for quite a while there wasn't it
wasn't just one strain but it was kind
of like the way that it was described on
um one of the documentaries I saw was
that the aim strain is like a race but
within that like there were a bunch of
individuals you know what I mean that
were like all slightly different but
they're like it you know you could tell
like DNA it was family resemblance but
they were all kind of like different but
it's like this was made to be like a
more virent strain and it was kind of
not entirely resistant to vaccines but
more resistant to vaccines than regular
Anthrax of
V so once they identified that this was
the aim strain like an American
strain um there was kind of confusion
for a time because it's called ases
which is a city in Iowa and so for a
long time they thought there was a
misconception that it came from Iowa
State University like the labs there um
but as I mentioned the strain actually
originated in Texas they actually
harvested it from a infected cow in
Texas and then later like grew other
things from it and experimented on it um
they only called it the aim strain
because it had been mailed from like the
I don't know the postmark on it was like
am Iowa or something like that but it
was actually like from Texas but because
of that there was like a big
misunderstanding about um there were
rumors going around that the that it had
been stolen from the lab in
Ames and the governor of Iowa at the
time he like sent all these state
troopers to like guard the lab at the
University and [__] like that and you
know all these researchers were trying
to send like all of these cultures that
they had like they had all these
cultures Anthrax cultures dating back to
like the 20s and they were trying to
send them to like the CDC and everything
but like nobody wanted them and it was
this whole thing now um Iowa State
University even though that wasn't where
the [__] came from but you know
everybody thought that it was um they
actually ended up destroying their um
Anthrax archive in October um because
they were like well we don't want
anybody stealing it like we just kind of
feel like there's hold so they just
destroyed it we don't need it so there
was that whole thing but like I said
that it didn't even originate from there
but the because of the rumors they did
that now um as I mentioned because the
first letters had been postmarked one
week after the September 11th attacks um
you know uh George Bush was in at the
time and they were very keen to relate
this so they were telling everybody that
was going out in the media to like you
know kind of imply that this is Middle
Eastern terrorist it's like connected to
911 it's connected to
Al-Qaeda um because they really wanted
somebody in the Middle East to be blamed
for this kind of situation even though
at this point they were pretty sure that
it had originated in the United States
because of the they they
wanted
more incidences to be Middle Eastern
origin to um justify attacking Iraq a
second time yeah yeah exct that's all it
was yeah they weren't they weren't
blaming Islamic people in general all
right like during the same time we still
had real good ties with Saudi Arabia and
Jordan so you know it was just it it
wasn't a blanket thing they just wanted
another reason to attack
Iraq yeah that's all I mean they were
coming up with all kind of stuff they
thought Iraq may have had something to
do with n 11 but they were just going by
Instinct just their fears said that and
they couldn't back off of
that then they started to say well he's
also got weapons of mass
destruction there was no evidence of
that they once used biological weapons
on the Kurds back yeah they did yeah
but Saddam okay bunch of [__] came out
later Saddam had asked all his guys he
says do we have have any of those
weapons left and they they were like no
we got rid of them all because they
started to become unstable in storage
and they're just too hard to
store um most of those weapons chemical
weapons had to be mixed right before use
but the separate components that to be
stored and they're toxic on their own
also yeah it's kind of pain in the ass
yeah and a lot of the stuff has
expiration dates on it where once it
goes beyond a certain date you have to
throw it away and dispose of it and
there's a difficult
disposal process and then you have to
make more of it so and then it just sits
on the Shelf
again Saddam or told him and said look
get rid of all that [__] chemical
[__] because because it doesn't matter
if we have it or not what matters is if
we have the knowledge to make it they
were like yeah yeah so they got rid of
it all they didn't have it CU why would
you just leave it laying around
especially if you knew that you were
under scrutiny L exactly and uh like I
said if you wanted to make it you could
just make it again Saddam was a dick but
the more I found found out about him
over the years the more of a good leader
Saddam was he was a very intelligent guy
he was nice he liked the West he was not
an enemy of the West that was something
the bushes kind of trumped
up yeah there was an attempt on his
dad's life on Bush senior's life
evidently yeah there was um that but
that was Vengeance because we betrayed
Iraq Iraq was our Ally we would been
we've been
supporting Iraq in their war against
Iran back in the
70s so Saddam was kind of a creation of
the United
States I was involved in all this [__] I
was in during the first Gul
war known dudes that were in both of the
wars I was doing [__] to support the
second
war in the Contracting League it
was America [__] makes more enemies
than it ever makes [__] allies it's l
lost all its allies now pretty much
we're yeah we're kind we're kind of bad
we're we're we're an outcast right now
Us in
Israel the bricks nations are all
against us because we [__] everybody
over everything we did we fell to
[__] and it's because the [__] United
States is
addicted to uh its uh defeating its
military-industrial complex and this is
all foreshadowed and foreseen by General
and President Eisenhower his parting
speech says this is a big threat to
democracy as we know it and he
absolutely right it's just a
runaway group of billionaires and
corporations that make money off all all
this [__] if we are at Perpetual War
they make money but it destroys us and
our
[__] and our uh
reputation your military and your War
fighting capability is supposed to be
defensive to to prevent invasion that's
what it's for it's not to create Empires
and punish people for not obeying us and
[__] like that that's really what we're
doing we're gangsters more than anything
else it's sad and it just kind of
devolved into this after World War
II but uh it's a shame it's coming to an
end though we're too weak to do anything
now thank God thank
God I'm sure a lot of other countries in
the world are Happ about that yeah
murder Hornet said uh was in Key West
and had con fritters with good as [__]
yeah con fritters are very good um Danny
says hey Tom when you lived in
Mississippi did you ever encounter
alligators there yeah they're in they're
in Mississippi they're all over the all
over I mean Florida's known for them but
they're all over the anywhere where it's
hot enough and there's kind of swamps
and stuff yeah any little artificial
pond on all the private land that my K
my my family and my family's friends we
call Ken and whatever they had we called
them Ken all those little ponds that
were filled with catfish and look filled
with little turtles and and [__] had
alligator in them some of them big man 7
foot long 7ot long alligator in there
and they wouldn't be there and then they
would appear out of the blue because
they're jumping from one Pond to the
next they can smell water miles away and
they'll walk across no like I said in
Florida I've seen alligators just
cruising across the highway just walking
walking yeah I'm going to this other
water I'm just going over there I'm just
like oh they get bored in in one in one
Pond there may not be males or Fem there
not they want to be around other
alligators they want to be where the
fish
are and uh as a little kid you know
Friends of the family would hire me to
go to their ponds to shoot all the
turtles and I was shooting Turtles with
all kinds of rifles 22250 shoot Turtles
on because Turtles are kind of like
cockroaches and in a um they're so
they're a lot cuter than cockroaches
they eat up all the [__] I know they
eat up all the little baby fish you're
trying you hey Turtles got to eat too
man yeah but we stocked those I know all
those fish were stocked you paid to
stock and then they're reproducing and
the little baby catfish and the brim and
[__] and the little turtles are eating
them and the turtles we didn't pay for
the turtles to be in there that's an
artificial Pond it doesn't look
artificial to a person who not from the
area
but the turtles are brought in by
they'll walk in there and I think maybe
turtle eggs get [__] hung up in bird
feathers or something I don't know now
Turtle AES are kind of big aren't they I
don't know but they are slightly get I
depends on the species they get in there
somehow Turtles [__] walk in there
and and lay eggs and the turtle snapping
turtles we're not talking about box
turtles there's a little it's a water
turtle i' be down there one one time I
must have killed 300 of them in a
day th is the turtle Destroyer
mhm they paid me like $20 this was back
in the'80s WoW $ whole dollars yeah was
in the 80s well yeah and that was like
13 that was a lot of money
yeah um merart says how you like that
Tom LOL so that must have been something
he sent you over I don't I don't know
one of his hookers booties oh okay yeah
yeah he's trying to make you like look
at your message like why you're trying
to like yeah he's trying to show me
these girls he's hitting are you drunk
murder Hornet yeah he's he's always
drunk I mean we are too so it's not that
big a deal uh Zan said they unearth the
tomb of Gilgamesh one year before we
invad into rack just say yeah then it
was never talked about again yeah uh
Joan y
yo that's how she talk to her all the
time right says hi guys yeah right there
right there wad says it's crazy right
now yeah it is uh Victor says we have
alligators here in San Antonio yeah
they're like all over the South big dog
says Tom and Jenny if you haven't yet
check out the movie Deliver Us from Evil
I've been hearing a lot about that I
definitely do want to see that like
either we'll review it or I'll just
review it by myself because I have been
wanting to watch that actually I've
heard a lot of good [__] about that so
we'll get into it but yeah so um do you
have anything else you need to add yeah
Joan Jer is somebody from our Gothic
Orlando oh okay yeah yeah that's who
that cuz like I said she's she's in our
local friend Circle oh okay yeah yeah um
I thought that name looked familiar I KN
I knew you've been like cuz she just
messaged me and I sent her a link to the
show oh okay there you go yeah all right
so where were we all right yeah this
happens all the time um
so what happened was that when this [__]
happened and they determined that the
anthrax bores were from the aim strain
which is a us-based strain of Anthrax
that they had been cultivating in uh
different Labs then they started looking
into you know a more homegrown kind of
thing to this end they honed in on a
scientist named Dr Steven hatville now
he was a biod defense scientist uh he
had worked for what they call uh I
believe they just pronounce it us AMD
which is just like this big long uh
acronym and here's the thing I was kind
of looking up about like this dude I'm
not a fan of this dude because of [__]
he did later but I'm not going to get
into that because it's not
relevant but um um because it's kind of
shitty like what they did to him
honestly they've honed in on him for as
I said I'm not in the FBI so maybe they
had information that I am not privy to
but it seemed like they kind of focused
on him initially because one he had
written a novel um which was very
similar to the anthrax letter attack
like that's what happened in the novel
like prior to it happening so they
thought that was a little suspicious
also he didn't have the greatest track
record in terms of his jobs like I said
he was a biod defense scientist um but
he had been fired from a couple of jobs
he had had some security clearance but
had lost it for reasons that I don't
believe were ever released to the public
at least as far as I'm
aware um so there was that um you know
he'd kind of
been which maybe on the front line
saying like oh you know the US
government they're not like prepared for
um an attack of this type and he was
even there were pictures of him in a
magazine where he was like shown like
cooking up different like plagues like
different biot terrorism [__] like in
his kitchen showing how easy it would be
so they thought that was like a little
bit suspicious you know what I mean so
they kind of honed in on him and I will
say that and this happens a lot I think
in law enforcement investigations
because like I said I write a lot a lot
about true crime and I'm really into
True Crime if you focus on one suspect
at like early in an investigation I kind
of feel like you get to a point where
you get get blinders and you're just
kind of like well this is our guy
obviously so everything that doesn't
point to that guy we're just kind of
like going to ignore that or write it
off or whatever but then like whatever
this guy does even if it's really not
that suspicious in the great scheme of
things is going to seem more suspicious
in context you know what I mean so I
kind of feel like that's what happened
in this situation there were a couple of
things that he did that seemed kind of
sus at the beginning and so they F like
laser focus on him and then it took them
a long time to shake that off that's
what I'm going to say about it he did
have an alibi at the uh you know for the
time that the mailings occurred and
stuff like that but that didn't really
seem to matter so they focused on this
guy for quite a while like he did work
in the biod defense area but he wasn't
he didn't work with Anthrax he was a vir
he said I'm a virus guy that's what that
was his area of expertise
he didn't really know a lot about
Anthrax he didn't like know how to make
it or how to make spores or anything
like that which is apparently like a
really difficult process and not that
many people know how to do it so uh you
know so he kept trying to say like look
man it wasn't me like I didn't you know
this isn't even my thing um but you know
there were some suspicious things about
him and they did have to look into it I
get
that um also they thought that he had a
motive because he had been fired from
yet another job
only like a month before the anthrax
attacks happened so they thought that it
was some kind of like vindictive sort of
thing and man they hounded the [__] out
of this dude um they just followed him
everywhere they searched his house they
didn't find anything particularly
damning um he was under surveillance
pretty much constantly um and at one
point uh the FBI like the people that
were watching him like ran over his foot
with their car um and they announced to
to the National media his name that he
was a person of interest so you know his
career was ruined his life was kind of
ruined [__] like that so basically they
kind of just considered him a suspect
for a long time now he eventually did
Sue um a you know after they had moved
on to the suspect who probably did do it
but he um he believed I've got I've seen
different like um figures like in the in
the media but it was between $4.6 and
$5.8 million settlement he got I believe
um because they kind of [__] up his
life a little bit um so yeah so he did
get a settlement in the
end but after they stopped focusing on
him what ended up happening was that in
2001 they did have like DNA and [__]
like that but it wasn't that great but
by the time 2006 2007 came along um you
know the DNA sequencing and [__] like
that was much more
uh you was much better so at this point
um the investigation kind of goes in a
different direction because the DNA they
uh sequenced The Strain uh you know of
the am uh variant that of the
anthrax and they actually in
2006 were able to pinpoint it to a
single
flask so this flask was under the um
kind of you know the guy that made it
and the guy that was had most contact
with it was a dude named Dr Bruce Edward
Ivans so they started concentrating on
this guy so this guy is a microbiologist
was a microbiologist he's dead now um he
had worked in the uh Army's biod defense
lab in Fort Dietrich in Maryland now the
thing about him is because he was so he
was definitely an Anthrax guy he was
actually one of the world's leading
experts on Anthrax and because of this
he was brought into the investigation
quite early on uh for his knowledge they
were asking him who would have the
knowledge to make Anthrax like this like
do you know of anybody that would done
so he was brought in and he was very
very helpful um at the very he gave them
names and all kind of stuff
um so the thing about it um he
particularly named two people in his
particular lab that he thought oh maybe
they were the ones that did it because
he was saying and they did find this out
from other experts later on that the
particular strain that was seen in the
letters was you wouldn't have just been
able to it wasn't like some [__] junk
ass [__] that you could just pull off
like it was the way that it was
processed you would need like some super
expensive like High Hightech um you know
equipment to do that you know what I
mean because I don't know how it all
works I'm not an anthro scientist
obviously not terrorist level they're
talking about nation state level yeah
they're say it's like somebody Maj
Corporation level yeah they're talking
about somebody that had really
specialized knowledge um to do this you
know so that's why they kind of started
asking all of these kind of top
researchers in the anthrax area like who
do you think would have done this blahy
blah so Ivans was they kind of looked at
him as a suspect or a person of interest
like sort of like early on in the
investigation but then after they
started concentrating on hatfill they
kind of forgot about him for a bit but
he was still like kind of helping them
with their investigation like giving
them all of this information and
stuff but after in 2006 when they
actually pinpointed you know they were
able to sequence the DNA of that
particular strain and they were able to
pinpoint exactly where it came from and
it all came from that one particular
flask so this one flask flask which just
had and there's pictures of it
everywhere it's just a a [__] flask
and it has like somebody wrote on it
with a sharpie RMR uh
one29 that was the flask number and this
flask had been begun and
maintained by Dr Ivans other people did
have access to it but he was the main
guy that uh had started it and had you
know had maintained
it now they started looking into when
they started suspecting him after the
DNA results came back they started
looking into his movements and his
history and things like that one thing
they discovered that not only would he
was he the main guy that had access to
this flask and that he was the one that
had started it but they also found out
that according to the lab records
because you know you kind of sign in and
sign out with your you know uh your card
or whatever um prior to the letters
being sent Ivans had spent a lot more
time in what they called the hot Suites
which are kind of the labs that you go
into you know if you have to work on
something that's you know biologically
volatile or whatever so it doesn't get
out um so he had logged a lot more time
into those labs than he ever had
previously in the days preceding the
mail outs which they thought was kind of
suspicious they also found out when they
looked into his background that the dude
had some mental problems big
time um so at this stage he becomes the
primary
suspect now one of the things that they
thought was maybe the motive for him
doing this was that they thought well he
actually had two Pat well he was not the
main he was the co-inventor on two
patents for Anthrax vaccines and they
thought maybe he's releasing at you know
Anthrax to like make people buy his
vaccines which kind of seemed like a
motivation at first but then like I've
seen a bunch of other scientists that
were like look I got all kind of patents
for vaccines and stuff you don't get
[__] money from that so it's like
there's just no it's like you get a
couple pennies here and there it's just
like not enough to like do this
elaborate thing but like I said I don't
know um but he did get I don't know if
he got any money from it but he did get
recognition from it like he got some
awards and accolades and stuff cuz like
oh look at this dude that's like working
so hard to like make vaccines for it and
stuff so there's that maybe that was
enough I don't really know because like
every every other scientist I saw that
had like some patents on vaccines it's
like yeah we don't get a [__] money from
that you know what I mean it's like you
had split it with like 50 bajillion
other people so it's not really that big
of a deal but yeah so there was that um
so according to um okay so another thing
that made them kind of like suspicious
of him and this is this wasn't super
clear like I kind of read this on a
couple of different sites and they
talked about it on the documentary as
well and I think I'm getting this right
but forgive me if I'm not so what
happened was that when they discovered
that the you know killer anthrax was the
aim strain there were several labs
around the United States that had access
to that strain it wasn't exactly the
same but they all kind of like worked
off of it you know what I mean so when
they discovered it was that they asked
all of those labs to send samples and
all of them did voluntarily including
his lab but the thing about it was that
he sent a sample at first if I'm
understanding this correctly he sent a
sample at first but apparently he didn't
send it right like it wasn't um I don't
know in the format that they needed or
he didn't he sent it incorrectly somehow
and they were just kind of like okay
we're just going to throw that away and
they asked him to send another
one and he he did send another one now
for a long time they thought that the
first sample that he'd sent had been
thrown away because they were like well
that wasn't right he didn't submit it
right you know what I mean now the
second sample that he sent didn't match
the [__] that was in the
letters however it turned out that the
first sample that he'd sent which they
thought had been thrown away it turned
out that somebody at some lab had saved
it because they're like well nobody told
us to discard it so we just saved it we
just archived it so later on when they
were like oh maybe we should take
another look at that and they tested
that one did match so he had
sent the the containment of the you know
the same one that was in the letters he
had sent that at first but he either
accidentally or on purpose didn't submit
it correctly and they threw and they
thought they threw it away but that
matched but then after he thought about
it he's probably oh well maybe I should
like fake it you know what I mean so
that's kind of a thing that seems and
they did kind of ask him about it's like
well why are those two samples that were
supposedly from the same lab like why
are they different and he couldn't
really answer that question so I thought
that was a little bit fishy but yeah the
first one did match the second one did
not so it almost kind of seemed like
after he thought about it for a minute
he's like oh I should probably fake it
because they could probably trace this
back to me like now that this is you
know this many years later cuz like I
said the [__] happened in 2001 this is
like 2006 2007 we're talking about so
it's been like several years so he's
like well they could probably catch me
so I should probably like send a fake
sample so they don't you know trace it
back to me there was that yeah allegedly
that's what I'm saying um so yeah now uh
so in the summer of 2008 they had enough
the FBI had enough um evidence to search
his house and at this stage um they
didn't find anything super damning as
far as that but they did find an
alarming amount of like guns and ammo
which they thought was a little bit
strange um and they also discovered that
he had been having a real hard time with
his mental health and had actually been
committed to an institution for a short
time uh in the summer of
2008 um because of like erratic behavior
and he was like making threats to people
and
stuff now while he was under
investigation and we're going to kind of
get into his past because I was kind of
interested in him as a person but what
ended up happening to him was that while
he was under invest tigation and um
shortly after he found out that he was
going to be indicted for the terrorist
attacks um in Late July of
2008 his wife Diane found him
unconscious at home I think he was in
his I don't remember if he was in the
bathroom or in the bedroom so he gets
taken to the
hospital and a couple days later he died
what he died of was an overdose of
acetaminophen um and he had been
observed buying a [__] ton of like
Tylenol or whatever it was like he was
planning it you know what I mean he was
62 years old at the time now they didn't
do an autopsy on him uh because they
said it was pretty clear that he had
committed suicide like it was pretty
obvious but I don't know what for
whatever reason they didn't do
one so um the cause of death on his
autopsy report was listed as liver and
kidney failure um he had bought two
bottles of Tylenol uh and apparently
taken them all and I think he he might
have mixed it with alcohol
too um and I think that when he went to
this is what I heard from like one
documentary when his wife took him to
the hospital because she found him like
he was still alive but he was like
unconscious so she calls 911 I heard the
911 call and um they took him to the
hospital and
they were basically like I think that
they asked
her if like they're like basically he's
gone or whatever and she said something
like I don't think he wants to be saved
so I think that she knew that he was
that he had done that you know what I
mean so after he died in 2008 um you
know only like a week later the FBI
comes out and they're like okay well
we've completed the investigation on the
anthrax attacks and you know we have
found that you know Dr Ivans was the
sole perpetrator like he didn't work
with anyone else anything like that um
but a lot of people really didn't buy it
especially I think mostly because the
FBI had spent you know whatever it was
five years like focusing on stepen
hafell when it was obvious that he
probably wasn't the dude that did it so
they're like well can we believe this
either you know what I mean so there was
that now the thing thing about it so
there's a lot of circumstantial
evidence um you know saying that Dr
Ivans was probably responsible like I
said it is weird that he was one of the
main Anthrax experts in the world and as
he even himself said um this strain of
Anthrax would have been very very
difficult to produce for somebody that
didn't know jack [__] about it you'd
have to have like really complicated
equipment and you would have to have
like really specialized knowledge and he
was really one of the few people in the
world that had that um he also had
unexplained time in the hot Suites like
what was he doing like before those
letters were sent there were also times
when he would check into the lab and
they didn't really know his whereabouts
for many hours at a time and they think
that it's possible that he could have
driven to that mailbox in New Jersey and
drop the stuff off because I think the
mailbox was like three a three-hour
Drive something like that and they're
like you know there's some time that
he's didn't have accounted for that he
could have done that so the thing about
it is that he had the opportunity for
sure but they never could have like a
Smoking Gun because when they searched
his house and everything like that and
they didn't find anything super super
damning other than all the guns and
crazy [__] but it's just kind of like
you know what I mean but he had mental
health issues obviously which we're
going to get into in a minute um I will
note though that all of his friends and
colleagues even though they thought he
was kind of a weirdo but you know what I
mean he's a scientist so they're like
you know he's kind of geeky and nerdy
and you know he was super ative like he
talked to mile a minute and all this
other kind of stuff but it's just kind
of like you know that was just him being
him they they really didn't think he had
it in him to do something like this um
and to this day a lot of his friends and
colleagues absolutely do not believe
that he was the one responsible um but
you know you never
know now the thing about it is
that so here's the
thing once they started looking into his
background uh the dude had some weird
[__] about himself they had he had a
very close friend who was a woman she
was like I believe she was like a
cooworker of his and for whatever reason
he kind of fixated on her and would send
her these emails about all of these
horrible mental health issues that he
was having like she was like I don't
know why he picked me like particularly
but he would send me this big long thing
like about all the [__] he was feeling
it was kind of crazy so because of that
she kind of um once he became a suspect
she was concerned and so she reported
her concerns to the authorities and so
she actually wore a wire and went and
had coffee with him or something like
that because they wanted to see if he
would say something
incriminating and he said something kind
of interesting he said that he would
sometimes he said in my right mind this
is what he said in my right mind I would
never hurt anyone that's what he said he
didn't say he would never hurt anyone
across the board he said in my right
mind I would never hurt anyone but he
also pointed out that sometimes he would
wake up and his car keys were next to
his bed and he would wonder if he had
driven somewhere without remembering it
so he was
having it appeared that he was having
blackouts um where he was doing [__] and
not remembering it or at least that's
what he
claimed he also claimed at one point in
one of his emails
that he felt as though he was like I
don't want to say like necessarily two
people but he felt like he was like
outside himself like watching himself
you know what I mean like he was
watching himself do things you know what
I mean like I said he had some issues so
let's kind of go back into this dude's
history because I thought this was kind
of interesting and it may kind of give
some insight into maybe why he did this
or not I don't know because like I said
they the thing about it even though at
first what they tried to like put a
political motive on it or like a
terrorist motive and stuff I don't think
it was that um it I just think that he
was kind of going with if it if indeed
it was him I think he was just kind of
going with the Zeitgeist of the time to
sort of Express his
own Neurosis if you want to call it
that so he actually originally was from
Lebanon Ohio now his parents were
Presbyterian but he later converted to
Catholicism which they thought was kind
of interesting and light of some [__]
which I'll mention
later now according to his older brother
he had a couple of older brothers but
according to this one brother their
mother was um whose name was
Mary was super super abusive not only
like physically abusive but also like
emotionally abusive the story was that I
think she had had two boys prior to
Bruce now Bruce was the youngest and
from what I heard from what he said
Bruce was like an accident like she got
pregnant on an accident and during her
pregnancy according to family members
she would apparently try to like bounce
down the stairs like on her butt like
trying to abort him
essentially and which is bad enough but
then after he was born she told him that
evidently I'm not excusing his behavior
if if indeed he did do this but I'm just
saying this is some [__] up [__] so
yeah apparently not only did she try
to miscarry him while he was in the womb
but when he was like old enough to
understand she was like yeah I tried to
do that like she told him you know what
I mean which you know that's got to do a
number on
anybody so there was that so um he
apparently was like fairly normal you
didn't even hear any of that did you no
like like that his mom tried to like
naturally abort him when he was in the
the womb by like trying to like jump
down the stairs she was preg cuz he was
an accident and then like later on like
after he was born like she was like
bouncing down the stairs well it might
it depend if you fell like in a
particular way yeah because have people
have miscarried like that before damn
but um but not only did she do that but
once he was born and was old enough to
understand she told him that wonder why
that she tried because she was
apparently a horrible person at least
according to like his brothers like said
that so like I said that would [__]
anybody up not excusing it I'm just
saying
so um you know he had a pretty uh he was
interested in science like pretty early
on and he did a lot of normal [__] he
seemed like a normal kid like in high
school you know he was on in the Honor
Society was in all science Dre stuff
like that um now he got married um to a
nursing student named Diane batch um
they stayed married until he died in
2007 2008 whatever it was uh she was you
know a housewife as they intended to do
back then now because DR ibans had been
raised Presbyterian but converted to
Roman Catholicism later on the
authorities after the anthrax attacks
they wondered if that in particular was
why the Senators dashel and Lehi were
targeted specifically because both of
them are Catholics and they are also
both pro-choice and so they thought well
that's a little strange that those two
in particular would be targeted
um so they thought maybe there was
something there I don't know if they
ever established a link but they just
thought that was kind of interesting um
because I don't know because Ivans did
have some weird like I don't know if
they weird but like kind of I don't know
like odd religious views in that regard
so they thought that maybe that was
something to do with
it now another thing this is so strange
so apparently when Ivans was in college
he
developed an overriding
obsession with one particular College
sorority Kappa Kappa
GMA this happened because he's one of
these [__] he asks one girl out
that was a member of that
sorority she turned him down and then
for decades afterward he seemed [__]
obsessed with that sorority so much so
that even much later when he was brought
you know when he was in his 50s or 60s
and he was brought in by the FBI and
questioned about this kind of [__] they
asked him about this because they found
out about it later on and he called it
quote unquote an obsession that he was
obsessed with this
sorority like he would he broke in there
at least once and took their the cipher
book you know they have that the book in
there with the ciphers that like um you
know uh decodes like all of their their
rituals and all that [__] you know what
I mean he stole that he didn't even do
like a panty raid he stole a cipher book
yeah he's trying to hit him where it
hurts I guess so he took that um and he
had friends in high school that said it
wasn't just the college thing it's like
he was like super resentful toward women
like even going back to high school like
that that guy remembered so there was
that
too dick was hurting uh yeah I guess so
I guess
so yeah so he and he would actually go
he just go in that sorority house like
where he was like he would go cuz you
know sorority I don't know huge amount
about like the the Greek system as they
call it but sorority houses you they
have chapters like at other colleges
right so he would go around to some of
the other colleges and break into those
sorority like the same sorority house he
at other colleges cuz he was super
obsessed with he bent on Vengeance I
guess like just because this one girl
was like no no thank you that's funny
dude's egos man you got to watch you got
to watch they're very fragile so
this dude they'll they're so fragile
that one woman says no thank you and
then he'll send [__] Anthrax to
people hold on that's nice let me
[__] clean this [__]
up she said dudes as if dudes are like
this dudes are not like this well those
are dud like this dud like there are
guys like that but not every dud the
same [__] just like not every woman's
the same yeah dudes like that are
[__] fragile you know what I'm
talking about that's just that's
hilarious to me they
they can't take they can't take the
rejection they get [__] butt hurt and
then they start [__] having fantasy
weird fantasies about power dynamics and
[__] I understand where you're coming
from I might have been like that when I
was like maybe like 13 or 14 but real
quick you realize that it's a numbers
game yeah you know I think most people
are like that when they pre teens are
teenagers cuz everything's the end of
the world that's just like teenag you go
no no no but once you get your mistakes
do the [__] again and again again and
again and it'll work out this eventually
just kind of yeah yeah yeah okay and
then you just kind of uh but no no just
cuz I can't
imagine one woman rejecting one man yeah
and he's back in the 60s back in and
then in the 2000s the dude is still
thinking about it right I don't even
remember [__] that happened in high
school and I'm not even as old as
something about the way dudes develop
that is that is out that is I developed
early crazy so you know I never had any
problems meeting women or getting
becoming friends with women or had any
problem with like seeing women as human
beings which seems difficult for some
types of dudes I don't know why that is
because the dudes are [__] take the
[__] too seriously they can't just
[__] relax and be normal and talk
like I said just a person yeah just a
person right and then the ones who are
who like you it's going to be easy you
know the other ones you might have to
pursue but really in my experience if
you have to pursue them too hard she's
not gonna stick she's just GNA try to
get some dick and [__] you know and
then she's gonna move on to the next
when she's riding the carousel you know
but that's just the way it is the ones
that are choosing you those are the ones
you got to focus
on uh but you know that's cuz that's
different but I always found
that women that went out of their way to
meet you are really kind of the ones
that are [__] going to end up panning
out a little bit
better um just my personal experience
like Jen Jen Jen made sure she met me
yeah you know I did go out of my way
yeah yeah and I and that and that should
be like very flattering to you because
that was not something I usually do I
knew at the time that was not she was
married though at the time yeah and we
just became friends uh because normally
I'm very shy I don't go up to people
like I'm just like they don't want to
talk to me going over there and you know
me and Jen have been together a long
time [__] what 12 years 13 years
maybe yeah and um yeah I told a story a
[__] thousand times already on the
[__] show we only got married
recently last September actually
September of 2023 but um we were friends
for like a couple years yeah like a year
and a half two or something like that
yeah we we'd hook up you know but then
we date people but we'd still hang
out a lot of that had to do with
influences of other
women other women were giving me advice
other friends are like you know you you
shouldn't [__] go out with her she
just broke up with her husband and she
needs to experience Freedom that kind of
[__] you know don't I was like yeah I
think was good advice I think that was
actually good advice it probably was
like I was kind of pissed off about it
at the time but I think I did need a
little bit of time just doing my own
[__] for a while and and the kind of guy
was I was actually getting more
gratification out of
Jen just being friends and hanging out
with her than I was is just like a
hookup I didn't really get much out of
hooking up I was hooking up with all
kind of [__] got pictures to prove I
hook up with the all [__] kind of
hotties doesn't necessarily mean the
experience was all that
good it just doesn't because
it there's a
lot dudes like to think that dudes like
to say that they [__] judge women
just on nothing but physical
attributes and personality attributes
it's more than that it's got to be like
a spiritual
element and um it's an
intangible you
know and 99% of the damn hookups there's
not that spiritual element there yeah
you don't really Vibe with them yeah on
on a certain level and like I said I've
done that too just like picking up a d
just like H you know you just but this
dude's pretty cool and yeah it might be
hot sex but then there just something
still doesn't really Vibe with you don't
like yeah then like the next day you're
just kind of
like you're like yeah she said she talks
[__] or she's kind of dumb or you know
what I mean like ah man she gets
annoying you know
or H she's already making unrealistic
demands I'm G get rid of this [__] you
know I mean there's all kinds of we chip
there's
that when it's right it just clicks and
it doesn't have to be
sexual at first or romantic it could be
a lot more different dimensions to it
well these dudes are like they're
getting back to the on the subject these
dudes right here they don't have a way
with women they don't have an
understanding of women or relationships
they don't and the reason why they don't
because they don't know themselves then
once they don't know themselves how can
they know anybody else well you kind of
got to work on yourself first before you
really get up anyone else the [__] right
and you never have a [__] you never want
to have the mentality of scarc
no the mentality of Plenty there are
many many many many women just like
there are many many many many many men
there's lots of people if something
[__] up with one it's not
over let that one go you got to try
again I mean we kind of talked about
that like on the whole twinflames
universe show because I think that that
cult yeah and it is a cult um kind of
relies on people being like oh this is
the one like the people and it's a
romantic idea and I understand why
people like it and I probably had that
when I was a teenager but it's like that
is a very toxic idea to get in your head
I'm not saying that like oh every person
is as good as every other person but I'm
just saying that there's no one be all
end all and if you [__] that up you're
lonely forever that is a very very bad
mindset to get into there's a certain
amount of people that you can Vibe with
sure you have a relationship with them
long term they'll be good but each one
of them will be slightly different yeah
doesn't mean I'm wrong or anything like
that Jen was dating guys that had that
[__] gone long term she would have had a
longterm relationship with them that
would have been good it wouldn't have
been like ours would have been a good
one yeah it's same thing it applies to
the men
too yeah like like I said I mean I you
know I was kind of like there's one guy
think of that [__] I know I was there
that that would have worked out had it
worked out I know who you're talking
about yeah that yeah that probably would
but that dude actually was not ready no
well one he was significantly younger
than me which kind of bothered me a
little bit it didn't seem to bother
wouldn't have mattered now had you stuck
with him though no no no because he's
been older um he was kind of coming out
of he had just gotten divorced too yeah
um and he was even at that time was even
less experienced than me yeah um so but
we had a good time we had a good time
yeah I still think of him fondly Jen's
listen to her no I'm just saying yeah
he's he's a good dude a good dude Tom
met him I like yeah he's a good dude
[__] uh Jen Jen had very low body
count especially compared to me which is
that that's something my advice is is
you kind of want to go with a woman
that's on a little lower end of a body
count because it's an indicator that
they commit that that you know that that
that they're not floating from dude to
dude just to make paychecks to get to
the next month yeah that was really
something that never occurred to me
right they have women that are like that
she want to stay with it's not body
count isn't so critical in men if you're
a woman listen to me it's not that
critical because sex for a man is not as
intimate it's not as evasive as it is
for a woman it can mean a lot of
different things for a man in in general
it's kind of more of a conquest than
entertainment first it can mean more
later if you know the like after you get
to know the bird yeah right it's
men control women control the sex they
they decide who's going to have sex and
who isn't men kind of control who's
going to have a relationship because the
guy can get the sex but then he leaves
he's like no I don't want so as a man
you have to understand that's your power
is you have the power to stay whether
not she wants you to stay or not but a
lot of women they just walk out my face
get the [__] out
of why are you still here now I have to
clean up after you the man's special
ability is that he can
stay that's the only thing you have to
offer because women can get sex
anywhere yeah I mean it might not be
great it probably won't be great yeah
they don't have the same motives of guys
they're not as sexually motivated like
I'm GNA go have sex with all these
different dudes yeah and put them on my
put KN on the belt and very rarely I got
women met some women like but it's very
very unusual they usually tend to be
young because there's a lot I mean we
have a lot more to lose like I said so
we don't we're a lot more cautious in
that regard so it's like you can't just
like go hit whatever you know what I
mean yeah usually those women even
though you might want to but I don't I
don't want to but usually those women
tend to be young the ones that actually
act on it not saying I don't like sex
because I do yeah you know how that goes
but it's just kind of like I'm not I'm
not into like sex with like a bunch of
random ass people because I'm like I
don't know you so it's not quite the
same experience yeah males of all
species they tend to like variety um but
they'll make cons they'll they'll
they'll make modifications and keep
themselves contained if it's to uh
nurture a relationship with somebody
they find is special you know what I'm
talking about like if you weren't
special I'd be I'd be
hit yeah that's kind of the default
setting for men well yeah I know yeah
why do you think we're so like
distrustful well they should be yeah
women should be that's why that's why
you shouldn't yell at me about it I
don't yeah but it's not uh it's not just
I don't think you would do anything that
I know of it's not just humans it's not
just human males it's males of all well
yeah anal species dude I read a lot
about evolutionary bi I know all that
[__] why do you think I'm so distrustful
of men in general yeah because I'm like
man it doesn't even matter what species
they are they're dicks in every species
no because our ancestors were spreading
seed that's what I mean yeah yeah I know
that right why do you think I don't
trust
nobody you could trust me I know how
[__] goes you can trust me I know
I trust you
99.9% which is more than I ever trusted
anybody ever so don't [__] me over I'm
just
saying just saying because I do trust
I've done nothing but deliver that's
true I've done nothing but deliver far
as I know I don't think you're doing
anything behind my back I don't think
you
are DVD Dragon said you see the love of
Jenny is much different than that of a
square that's right
see a pimp love is very different y
haven't seen uh [__] idiocracy go see
idiocracy it's a masterpiece yeah DVD
Dragon also says life is just a carousel
of dick for some girls sometimes it
seems well not for me it doesn't seem
like that but I mean it's it's a
carousel to me it's not a carousel of
dick it's just it's one dick but it's a
good dick you know what I mean that's
it's fine uh that's that's a lot of the
teenage girls in early 20s they're like
I didn't even do that at my well like I
said if I'm I kind of had a different
situation because I wasn't super [__]
when I was my teenage years and then I
got married at 22 and I never cheated on
the dude and I was married for 14 years
yeah and then I got divorced I was about
37 38 then I kind of went Buck Wild for
like a year and a half but even then
like I didn't go too crazy yeah CU I'm
just not that kind of person her body
counts less than 10 maybe less than 15
it's maybe eight yeah I think eight yeah
is is what it is she deserved that [__]
man I was there she deserved to go
[__] run wild for a little while yeah
and like I said even then I didn't run
that wild no no not comparatively no it
was real I was there it it was pretty
pretty lowy lowy I was there at the club
I knew I saw the guys yeah I was fing
you know talked to them [__] it was
only a handful seriously and like I said
that was all kind of like in that one
time because I was married a long time I
married young and I didn't cheat on that
dude that whole time yeah cuz I cuz I
don't do that I just and then me and J
said well I guess we're a couple then
and then everybody was we [__] we didn't
even talk about it didn't talk about it
it just happened I remembered very
distinctly we were at um venue 13 yeah
we were outside on the patio we were
talking to somebody about something and
you in the convers in the course of the
conversation you referred to me as my
girlfriend as your girlfriend yeah yeah
yeah and I looked at you like and then
after the person left I was like so what
was that about you're like uh I don't
know I was like so is this a thing now
or yeah I guess so that that was how
that happened yeah well it happened
natur I guess so yeah I was thinking of
you as my
girlfriend because you had never like
referred to me like that before but you
know it's funny you know I'm very
flexible I'm not like people look at me
and they might want to [__] judge me
and trying to say like what kind of guy
I am or anything even during that time
when I considered you my girlfriend you
could have dated other guys for a little
while I yeah okay but it was just you
were my girlfriend at that time yeah
yeah we were together like all the time
yeah we were together all the time yeah
yeah we we [__] lived together almost
I was I was either staying at his house
or he was staying at my apartment pretty
much all definely best friends yeah and
we only hooked up every now and then
every now and then we throw it down yeah
but it wasn't like the central thing of
the relationship yeah we were all just
like hanging out like we were [__]
having good with the club and talking
about [__] food and clothes and [__]
Danny says what's Tom's body count
number do you even remember no he
doesn't remember it's uh it's got to be
triple digits it's got to be in the
hundreds triple digits yeah I mean just
from what I know about you well I got
photographs for a
lot um yeah because it's got to be at
least leaving High School I was at least
30 right and then just before I
graduated and then like I said you know
and it was on two continents well not
not two it was it was both in America
and in Brazil so I grew up in Brazil
with Brazilian girls and they were very
Advanced you know what I mean we hit a
lot of those and then when you were in
the Army when you were in the Army you
were going to the the brothel and Korea
Kore and that was like a different
really didn't add up to that many though
yeah cuz you didn't get only got off
once every month and I was only there 12
months and I may have average maybe two
a month right you
know but still
I mean you've got you're EAS but the
thing if I was a girl I wouldn't be
counting the hookers but I'm a man I'm G
Count everything I count if why wouldn't
girls count hookers a girl probably
wouldn't count they oh that doesn't
count oh I didn't like him so that don't
count oh I pay for that one I wouldn't
count I think a girl probably wouldn't
count that if she I count all that [__]
so and if it's sex it counts yeah I
don't care if you paid for it or not
yeah and here's the thing um no I I
really appreciated my time in Korea but
they're little tea house girls and I
liked them they're nice um they were
just I was in my Army and they were in
their army that was serving my country
they were serving their country trying
to get all the money out of us and get
it in the Korean economy and they were
uh I respected
them other Koreans probably didn't
respect them but it was an illicit it
was legal there but not it was like
gisha type
entertainers I guess that's more a
classy way to put it
but hey they're working like anybody
else like I said I'm a big advocate of
not [__] on sex workers yeah cuz it
one it is a hard job I would not do it
unless I was super [__] desperate
yeah you know yeah I'll do porn video
and live stream and stuff like that but
I'm not like [__] random dudes for
money [__] that solo scenes and doing
scenes with me yeah which like I said we
would be doing that anyway so that's not
like weird but um and honestly anybody
that can do escorting and stuff like
that and make money out it I kind of
admire that cuz I would not like a
secret agent I would not do that oh yeah
I wouldn't want my daughter to do it but
it's not me it's that's for you then
that's for you it's not for I would not
be good at it because I'm not good at
faking yeah oh my God you're so awesome
like some [__] 60-year-old fat dude
comes up to me and it's just kind of
like o and I have to like pretend to be
into that I'm not girlriend experience
I'm not good at
that and I'll admit I know my weaknesses
I'm not I'm not good at that it's fine
if I don't have to see the person if
it's live stream and it's just kind of
like I can't see you're just like a name
on the screen actually they when they
turned the camera on we have seen them
they're normal guys well all of the
dudes that turn the cameras on they all
look good have been young and and pretty
buff yeah they're fit yeah so I kind of
feel like we've never had an experience
where we were live streaming and like
somebody turned on and it was like some
80-year-old weirdo yeah never it was
always like a dude in their 20s or 30s
in usually good shape
yeah me and Jen in in the video scene
were attracted mostly uh bisexual
British guys who worked out a couple
American guys who are my are my favorite
guys yeah nice guys nice guys they W
they're all super polite yeah weren't
creepy at all they just want to play
they just want to play games across the
[__] they just wanted to have like a
virtual thre them yeah that's all it was
yeah it wasn't weird at all and they
were super nice me wasn't even weird for
me and I'm straight but I know what he's
after so I'm just putting on a show for
him you know and [__] you know know
showing Jen and getting him to show off
and [__] you know cuz you got want to
make him the show too if he's got the
camera on I mean if they turn the camera
on then there is then he wants to be
part of the show too so but it's weird I
don't think I've ever everybody that
turned their camera on was like a
reasonably attractive person yeah if
they if they're not attractive they're
not going to turn the camera unless
they're some kind of weirdo that's just
kind of like hey they get off on making
everybody look at their ugly ass but we
haven't had anybody I know there's
people out there like that but we never
had anybody like that Oscar says don't
lie about that body count y' seriously
I'm not lying about mine I think it's
eight and I'm 51 but like I said I was
married for a long time in there I was
married
from I got married at 22 in
1995 and uh we divorced in
200 N 2010 2009 or 2010 I can't really
remember but yeah we were married a long
time like 14 years or something like
that and like I said I never cheated on
that dude I just because I don't do that
if I commit to you I commit to you I
don't [__] around I just I don't know I
just I don't do that I don't want it
done to me so I don't do it to other
people you know what I'm saying so
there's that I just I just wouldn't do
that uh DVD Dragon said you couldn't buy
anything with paycheck from a
dick probably not dick is not worth
anything well I wouldn't say that
necessarily but
but I don't know it's just kind of out
there kind of out
there
um Tammy says that's what you're gonna
see when I show up an 8-year-old
weirdo I would love it Tammy I would
love it if you would show up and turn
the video on turn the video on Tammy dmy
yeah she said that's what she that's
what you're going to see an 80-year-old
weirdo she's I've seen Tammy's
photos Tammy's a normal kind of she's
she's a good looking middle-aged chick
you want more of that yeah she's our age
let me have one more all right that was
what I've only had like two right this
is going to be drink three okay I'm
going to make it week though I mean I
started early I started at like
6:30 because I was like I was getting um
before like an hour before the show
started I was like man I think I'm gonna
just make a drink and pregame a little
bit I've been watching Night Gallery
because I want to do on my scare Salon
Channel which if you haven't subscribed
to that go over and subscribe to scar
Salon I haven't put a video up on there
for a long time so I was like holy [__]
I really need to do that so I was like I
really need to get back into my Night
Gallery videos because I bought the
[__] whole series on DVD right so I'm
still working my way through season 2 so
I got like halfway through season like
I'm on I did episode s episode
8 and then I just started writing about
episode 9 so I'm kind of hoping that I'm
going to try and watch him like in bits
and like write about it as I go and then
do a video about it so hopefully it'll
be up by either this weekend or by
Tuesday because I really want to put
something up on there but I really like
Night Gallery and I know a lot of people
like those so I'll do Night Gallery and
I'm still doing Thriller because I have
a million of those episodes left too Mur
horn said this is like a Friday show I
know well I mean we're almost to the end
we just like started talking
about Bruce Ivans and his weird
obsession with sororities and that kind
of got us off on a whole thing so I'm
not really sure okay so the dude so not
only is he like obsessed with this very
particular
sorority so much so that he's driving to
other colleges where this sorority has a
chapter and is also breaking into that
[__] which I don't understand that but
okay
whatever but there was another
woman um Nancy heg would who's a a
doctor now but um she was like um I
guess they were both at the University
of North Carolina together and when uh
he was uh post-doctoral at that point
and he kind of became obsessed with her
at that time and she accused him of
stalking her and stealing her notebooks
that had like all of her work in it
which okay um and and like [__] up
her apartment and [__] like that so this
dude I'm not saying this makes him a
biological terrorist because these are
two different things but it is weird
that he has this kind of history and
this kind of like long running
obsession with these women and he's like
breaking into their he's not raping them
or nothing like that as far as I know
but he's just like breaking to like
stealing stuff and then he's like
obsessed with them and he's like sending
the message Mees and like stalking them
and stuff that seems a little weird is
all I'm
saying um you
know he later admitted and he admitted
this himself in his own words to the FBI
after he was a suspect and they started
questioning him about [__] he said that
something he would do a lot was that he
would put a pistol in his waistband he
would go to like a really shitty part of
town at night and
deliberately walk through dude's like
like groups of young men hoping that
somebody would do something I guess so
he could shoot them so he's not like the
most mentally stable person ever is what
I'm
saying now because the you know they
figured out that the anthrax letters had
been sent from this
particular uh you know post box in uh
Princeton New Jersey now this particular
box it so happened
was like across the street from a place
where that sorority
kaaa kept a bunch of their stuff like it
was a storage facility for their for
that
sorority so they thought that was a
little suspicious but when they kind of
looked into that they couldn't find any
physical evidence that tied him to that
because nobody ever saw him dropping the
[__] into that mailbox for example um
there were no um
you know uh for another example like
there were no receipts like from a gas
station in the area perhaps that would
have tied him to that area they could
never Place him in that area which is
one of the things that made people maybe
doubt that it was him they did say that
he'd had had ample time to drive back
and forth from that mailbox because it
was about 3 hours away but no one ever
spotted him at that particular mailbox
they just thought it was weird that that
mailbox box was right across the street
from like a Kappa Capa GMA like storage
place and he happened to have an
obsession with that sorority not saying
that makes him guilty I'm just saying
that's a little suspicious so again
that's a little kind of like more
circumstantial
evidence now in 2008 the FBI released a
bunch of emails which Dr Ivans had
written and as I mentioned a lot of
these were addressed to this um
cooworker slri of his who he had for
whatever reason um decided that he was
just GNA um you know kind of pour all of
his uh [__]
onto and he um
went a lot into uh his anxiety his
depression his
paranoia in these now he had seen a
therapist for this he was on medication
for
this um and the thing about it was that
he was diagnosed
with um you know some psychiatrists that
looked at it thought that he maybe had
some type of
psychosis but they also couldn't rule
out the possibility that he was maybe
faking uh for whatever
reason now they also did this kind of um
like a panel of you know behavioral
experts and stuff like that and to kind
of look into his mental health
background one thing they did determine
that um that they thought thought was
interesting was that they believed that
the Army had not done
sufficient due diligence in assessing
his mental state before allowing him to
work with Anthrax you know what I mean
um you know so they're like well maybe
they do well yeah that's what I mean
they're just saying that in hindsight
probably not a great idea to let him
work with like a bioweapon like that
it's like when I was in the [__]
Recon Pon 101st was in the first 327 all
our snipers had to under go like a
psychological evaluation before they
[__] went through sniper School the
sniper School candidates before they
sent them CU I I worked with snipers but
I was in a uh I was
in one of the Scout squads the snipers
were fourth Squad they were like our
support they have to give them a certain
secret clearance also too before they
can actually send them to sniper school
but if you actually look at what they're
man it is so [__] rudimentary it's
more like legal paperwork that they have
to go through just to say okay we did
our [__] okay go to the school there's
nothing to that yeah I don't think they
look they well they clearly did not in
this they can't predict who's going to
be a psycho when you're
[__] have an entire Army of psychos
that you're trading to be Killers the
whole [__] arm is like that you know
what I mean what you're talking about
that's that's why they're there that's
what I mean I kind of feel like I I
don't like like to you know cuz we talk
about a lot of True Crime cases and
we're just like hey you know this person
this person that later turned out to be
a seral killer like when they were a kid
they did
XYZ um you know and we like to think oh
why didn't somebody stop them back then
but it's just like kind like if you went
back in a time machine and you saw that
[__] happen I kind of feel like it would
be [__] people would like wow that was
[__] up but I don't think they
would you know put the same importance
on it that they got other kids doing the
same thing nothing happens to them and
then like nothing happens so it's just
kind of like you can't like you said
it's really hard to like predict
people's future Behavior like a lot of
kids do [__] up [__]
um and you can't always predict oh that
person is going to be a seral killer you
know what I mean so who could have
predicted Lee Harvey Oswald that's what
I mean you can't you can't really like
you know unless it's super egregious
unless it's super egregious and I'm not
convinced Oswald wasn't working for
somebody you know he seemed very he was
involved in a lot of CIA stuff like the
free Cuba
movement you know do I think he acted
alone
no so having somebody do a quick Eva
mental evaluation in some military unit
somewhere given by prob you're never
going to [__] find out if that I me
you'd like to think that they were a
little bit more uh stringent when
someone was going to be working with
like bioweapons but apparently not it's
hard to it's hard to pick through them
well and like I said everyone's humans
humans are just doing their jobs um most
people when they go to their jobs they
just kind of [__] their way through
and get a paycheck you know what I mean
I get that and he only has to act right
for the interview that's it and then
he's got the [__] intellectual skills
to do what he's being asked to do which
is make bioweapons all right it's
probably hard to find a dude who who's
got the skills to make bioweapons
they're not going to eliminate him
they're going to say well D really good
at we don't really qu kind of crazy yeah
we also don't quite trust you so we're
going to have to [__] throw you out
of the batch when you're no more or less
crazy than any other [__] Bing
buy a
weapons I mean you kind of have to be
sort of crazy to like want and you only
have to [__] act real sane for the
[__] interview true which I probably
anybody could do that well Bundy could
have done it unless you were super crazy
Ted buy could get through any of that
well why do you think that like serial
killers get away with [__] for such a
long time because for short periods of
time they're able to act like a [__]
normal person they know what normal
people are looking for they're not
stupid which is more than I can do I
can't act like a normal person but I'm
not a serial killer again either respond
like a normie yeah so you know I don't
know what normies respond like I have no
idea right but like I said I'm not a zal
killer so I got that going for me
um Danny said uh Tom's got a highman
trophy case no I don't
only had one dudes are impressed though
right only had one virgin and that was
after I got out of the army when I was
like 20 something and she was 20s
something my name is Alexandria that's
all I'm gonna say of in Boston nice girl
oh I never heard this story I tell you
that you can tell me that
later yeah don't say it on the show
because somebody might somebody might
dox her yeah not I mean that's unlikely
but I'm just saying yeah she's got a
bunch of kids now we talk about a lot of
people on the show and I'm always just
kind of like man should we do that cuz
like people could find cuz all they have
to do is like look at our friends list
they know who we're talking about she
was in her 20s and she just wanted to
get it over with so you want to get it
over with yeah okay yeah I need people
that we're get it over with yeah like
once you get to that age you're just
like Jesus Christ it's just kind of like
I really should have done this by now
yeah and she had like mental things
about it you know what I mean oh you're
going to have to tell me this story yeah
I was like it's not a big deal tell me
this story it's not a big deal I just
popped it and jumped off of her
oh that [__] hurt it it does kind
[__] said yeah just heal up we'll do
it again later like [__] it's not so
fun the first time like not for girls
that's not no I just popped it for it's
kind of painful and it's just but after
that it's fun but it's like she got into
it but it took weeks now couple lat heal
up that's not always that's not always
the case though because I do I do know
some girls that were like oh my my first
time was like so awesome but it's just
kind of like mine was
not great
but it wasn't sucky yeah like it was
kind of fun but it was also kind of
shitty you know what I mean so it was
very I told her since you're not going
to like
it yeah I mean I mean generally it's not
like I said it's not I said look we'll
just [__] get the [__] up she yeah
yeah get over get over with yeah and
then [__] you know
so man I can't believe I'm [__]
telling this story well I told you you
could tell it to me later but you just
kept on blabbing yeah yeah yeah I like
you do I just [__] did it and jumped
and
[__] she ran off the [__] bathroom
and [__] and she's like I can't believe
I did says yeah you did but it says
that's not what sex is though it was
like it'll be much better later yeah
just heal up okay and then like the next
week and then next week she wasn't
really into it but then like a couple
weeks later she go oh I understand this
now yeah you know like yeah yeah yeah
it's much better later yeah yeah like
the first time you're just kind of like
what the [__] is going on this she get
this is not fun you know what I mean she
could do everything else though she'd
been you know oral and playing around
and [__] but she never did that
right TVD Dragon says Tom launched
operation hman spear I think people are
too like um obsessed with virginity it
seems like a weird thing but I was
uncomfortable around it I was just the
[__] women that had some miles on
them right they were ready to [__]
party people get too they they put too
much importance on it yeah cuz like I
said especially for girls like the first
time it's like probably not probably not
going to be a fun time it was like a
mental block just get it over she she
felt very in it'll be fun later she
actually felt
inadequate like she was everybody else
was because everybody else was ahead of
her yeah everybody else had already done
it and she was cute she was very cute
but she was scared of it right well like
I said yeah it's kind of I kind of had
the same situation CU I was a little bit
older right than average and yeah you do
get that you feel kind of like a loser
because it's like oh everyone's like
most of my friends have done it and you
know and it's just kind of like you know
like I said first time was kind of fun
but also kind of sucky yeah you know
what I mean it got much better later it
gets much better later like when you
know what you like and you know how to
do [__] you know what I mean first time
is like not fun but yeah so where were
we okay so um so this
dude yeah so like I said they didn't
really go into his background but like
you said that's not all that
unusual um now the thing about it was
that I think a lot of the psychiatrists
that examined him like later on thought
yeah he does kind of fit the profile of
somebody that would be the anthrax
killer you know what I mean now it did
come out later that his one of his
counselors who was a social worker name
her name was um Jean dly now she
actually ended up having to file a
protective order against him she claimed
that he had stalked her and threatened
to kill her um and had done so for quite
a long
time now she said that she had treated
him for six months and at the end of
that time she later told authorities
that he was kind of losing his [__] and
said that he was going to quote go out
in a blaze of
glory um so there was that Z says Thomas
say you're not going to tell the story
then he goes and tells the whole story I
didn't tell the whole [__] story
you're going to tell me that story I'm
teasing you're going to tell me that
story later I'll tell you the story I'm
going to ask you you'd like that story
it it was funny would I yeah yeah we'll
see why wouldn't you I don't
know I'm just saying that was a long
time ago but see that's what I mean it's
like that was like 96 it's hilarious
because Tom would be like I'm not going
to tell you that and then he'll tell you
anyway he'll tell you
anyway another thing he does too is that
he'll like ask me a question he'll ask
me a question and then before I can
answer it he'll just like keep talking
like he tries to like like he's going to
answer for me or he's giving me all
these options or something I'm like can
I answer or yeah he'll just like keep on
talking but he does that all the time so
I'm kind of used to it I've known him
forever but yeah so I'm going to hear
that story like later
on I'm GNA hear that story later on
because I'm always kind of interested in
this they kind of I know this is [__]
up I'm a girl um I know this is [__]
up but they may be kind of mad even
though he didn't know me back then
obviously but I'm just kind of like they
may be kind of mad but I kind of want to
hear about it anyway even though it kind
of makes me mad I don't know I know it's
stupid I I don't know I'm admitting it
but yeah
so so yeah so this woman who was his
counselor said that he threatened to
kill her all this other kind of stuff
now she said she reported this
information to the FBI I'm assuming like
when he first became a suspect for this
[__] um and she even forwarded them uh
phone messages that he left her where he
was like yelling at her like you did
this and like blaming her for like all
the [__] that was happening um you know
even though it was his craziness clearly
that got him in trouble now the thing
about it though was that because Jean
dly was uh she had a checkered past
let's call it that um when she was
younger she had been uh according to her
own admission like in a biker gang and
she'd been like on a bunch of drugs and
stuff like that um um you know she kind
of got her [__] together later and
became a counselor or whatever but um
because she had that in her past and
Ivans did not have a criminal history um
I feel like they didn't really listen to
her at first uh so there was that I kind
of feel like in until there was more
[__] about him like more women coming
forward and saying yeah he stalked me
too like they didn't really listen to
her cuz she did try to um you know warn
the FBI prior to that so um she told
them one of the things she told the FBI
was that um according to his sessions
with
her that Ivans had what she called and
this is a quote a detailed homicidal
plan to kill his
co-workers and he had developed this
after um you know figuring out that he
was going to be tried on capital murder
charges like for the thing so because of
this a lot of people have to well maybe
he didn't even do the anthrax attacks
but because he got blamed for it he lost
his [__] because he already had like
mental health issues up to this point
I'm not really sure where I fall on that
like he clearly did have mental health
issues going back to high school and
perhaps prior he was horribly abused as
a child both physically and mentally um
and you know it it does seem like he had
some problems later on with obsessive
Behavior stalking things like that
now was it enough to have made him
essentially take revenge on society
Maybe by doing an Anthrax attack like
pretending it was a terrorist attack or
did he just go nuts after he got accused
of it and then he just like lost his
mind either of those two scenarios are
believable to me so I'm not really sure
where I stand on it but I am kind of
leaning more toward he probably did it
because of the other
circumstantial evidence as in you know
that that particular um strain of
Anthrax coming from that particular
flask which he was kind of in charge of
yes other people had access to it but he
was the guy that was in charge of it he
was the one that had started it he was
the one that you know knew where it was
at all times it was in his possession
things like that and there were other
things that made me kind of think that
maybe he did it but I don't know I mean
he did seem like he had some issues as I
said
um now the thing about it was that
um so they gave
him I don't know I guess they gave him a
lie detector test and at first I think
he passed it you know what I mean I
think they gave kind of everybody like
lie detector test and I think he kind of
passed it but I'm not really sure if
that
is here or not nor there but there's
kind of
like the people that think that maybe he
didn't do it they're like well this
particular strain of Anthrax that came
out in the letters was
probably too complicated too
sophisticated for one single person to
have
done um so and as I said a lot of the
people that knew him that were friends
of his that were colleagues of his that
worked alongside him for a long time
absolutely and to this day as far as I
know still refus to believe that he
could have done
that
but I don't know the thing the [__]
about it is though that stuff that he
said voluntarily to the FBI and to his
friend like when he was when she was
wearing a
wire he seemed to
have some kind of thing where he was
like dissociating it almost seemed like
he and he seemed aware of it but so it's
possible that he could have been doing
[__] in this other iteration of himself
that he maybe wouldn't have done because
I found it instructive that he very
specifically said to her cuz she was
asking him like look Bruce did you do
this and he kind of paused for a long
time and then he
said in my right mind I wouldn't hurt
anybody and I thought that was kind of
interesting that he made that
distinction because he did seem to know
that he maybe allegedly was doing stuff
without his conscious knowledge like he
was blacking out and doing stuff well if
that's true then he probably did it
that's what I'm saying so that's kind of
made me like because it's like I'm not
and I'm like I said I'm not exonerating
him I'm just saying that if he did it he
had mental issues so severe that maybe
he was doing it without his conscious
knowledge cuz he's like I would wake up
sometimes and my car keys would be like
right there on my nightstand and I'd be
like oh [__] that I drive somewhere and
do something and I don't remember it you
know what I mean and it could be that he
was just making that up I think he made
that up but maybe not he may have just
had darker
impulses and maybe a good person but
he'd have these we watched this thing
last night where the damn serial rapist
I'm like
American Nightmare watch that you guys
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy he's
actually calling the cops to try to back
up the [__] the girl story that no no
no I did rape her don't because they
were going to send her to jail for what
he did this rapist whole thing this
rapist is actually having like
protective
feelings for his this one of the
weirdest [__] things I have because
yeah I could kind of I can understand
what he's doing as a man yeah I
understand it too but it's still pretty
weird he was living a fantasy he had
this fetish rape fantasy see but in his
mind he loved those girls he cared about
them he didn't want to see them get in
trouble for what he did to them and one
girl talked her way out of getting raped
he found out she'd been raped before and
he's like oh man somebody raped you oh
man okay well then this is how you
protect yourself then he goes on to
teach her how to protect himself from
rapist and maybe should get a dog yeah
you should get and then he leaves
because he doesn't see himself as a
rapist he thinks he's Don
Juan that's what Xander is saying he's
compartmentalizing it and I think that a
lot of people that do this kind
we were watching night was like is the
C like I get it fromt I've read enough
about rapists and murders and stuff like
I get I don't feel that like I can't um
empathize because I don't feel that way
myself but intellectually I can
understand how they came to that
conclusion let's put it that way so so
this dude the way he's acting is like
super strange and which just like the
[__] that he was like I kind of feel
like he
was he had this whole fantasy scenario
but I I told Tom I was just kind of like
I feel like a lot of dudes that rape
women not so much you're breaking into
your house and raping or jumping out of
the bushes but kind of more date rape
kind of thing yeah I think I don't know
what the percentage is but I think a
large percentage of those dudes do not
think of themselves as rapists they see
themselves more as an opportunist I
think and they care about this woman
they like them so it's not rape that's
in their mind in their mind which is
kind of disturbing from a women's point
of view but yeah that particular rapist
who we were talking about
before I was putting myself in his shoes
and his act and I go oh I know what he's
doing yeah he was raping those women but
he loved them he yeah he love he he
cared about them you know what I mean
and he want to think see anything bad
happen to him he wasn't beating him up
or
anything not that that made it any bad
I'm just he he he's got this fantasy
that he's like Don Juan and that what
he's doing is a good thing in a certain
way he's alleviating the choice he's
alleviating the stress off the woman in
his mind she doesn't have to choose you
know what I mean because she doesn't
want to choose it makes her more
innocent in his mind so he cherishes her
more yeah because she didn't choose to
have sex yeah so she's more almost like
virginal yeah yeah it's against you said
that might be
because they found out later if you
haven't seen American Nightmare please
watch it it's a crazy [__] story but
if um that's why when they found out
later this same dude had broken into a
woman's apartment yeah and tied her up
and put a like blindfold thing or it
wasn't even blindfold it was like a swim
goggles with duck with blacked out tape
on them and it was like um you know I'm
sorry to inform you but I have to rape
you and I'm just like Oh goodie yeah um
but then after she started like freaking
out and saying that she'd been raped
before yeah yeah he didn't do it yeah he
says well I can't bring myself to do it
then what he said and like you said it
might have been a thing where she
thought where he thought like oi was
sullied but also because like you said
he might have been perceiving as like
innocent yeah the innocence was gone
right and so he couldn't really get into
it anymore right and he he wanted her to
be innocent and that it's happening
against her will all right he's going to
be nice to her during this but it's
still against her will which makes her
innocent so she cannot be like it's not
sinful you know what I mean which seems
like a very very Weir Twisted way
Twisted yeah a very Twisted way this
dude seemed to have a very very specific
fetish and so he's not it's not done in
his mind out of any kind of
hatred he sees this as love in a certain
way he loves
them which is that's some weird [__] man
like I said but when the when the cops
started to lock one of the victims up
for for making up the story no he said
no I did do it he's sending them all
kind of evidence he says don't lock her
up I did it yeah pictures and [__] he's
coming to her defense why would he come
to her defense he could let her go down
for the crime he be it's because he
cared about her he didn't want her to go
to jail didn't want her to go to jail
because they thought she was making it
up because the story was so [__]
crazy he had a uh he had an emotional
connection to her her Purity and her
innocence got to PE yeah weird it was
very weird it's a weird weird way
I did not expect but it's just kind of
like a a weird mixture of [__] the
diabolic and the [__] kind of weird M
mixture of [__] diabolical and
[__] human you know what I mean he
was uh kind of a very human guy he kind
of he cared about the victims which is
unusual because a lot of times they'll
kind of escalate and he started off as a
Peeping Tom and all that which that's
the
normal in some way s that happens a lot
with peeping th they become serial
rapists and then they modify themselves
into serial
killers that particular
guy had he been caught sent to prison
and then released like what have
happened that's what would happened back
in the
70s he would have started killing the
victims and then he would have became so
to to avoid prosecution and um then he
would have become a serial killer
they're all dangerous it's a that's a
dangerous way of [__] thinking about
things and it all has to do with [__]
sism so when a man or any person puts
them in the center of the universe it's
like an extreme form of
narcissism the D is a narcissist he
loved him so therefore they didn't have
right to say no to him and when they
didn't say no to him it made them even
more valuable to him because they're
innocent and he cherished them more
that's a weird way weird so weird I'm f
kind of Stu but a female equivalent to
that would be to have sex with a guy and
then once he was F fall asleep you kill
the man that way he can't cheat on you
and he'll be loyal to you forever that
would be the M that would be the female
equivalent right but how often does that
happen not very often it
doesn't just saying but that would be
kind of like the way way a female would
do it and honestly that would never even
occur to me yeah uh Zach says I just
Googled the guy from American Nightmare
and there's a jail interview with him he
has a smile and thumbnail and God it's
so creepy yeah that dude is like super
creepy and the thing about it is that
he's one of those dudes
that he was you know reasonably goodlook
he's a little weird like you could tell
he was a little weird like just by
looking at him but he was like
successful he was a
lawyer um you know he had a job and [__]
like that but he was doing all this [__]
on the down low and they found out later
after the case that American Nightmare
was about they found out later that he
was probably the same dude that was like
creeping around peeping in Windows and I
said that's kind of
why I'm not saying you should like you
know um bring the hammer down on every
single person that's like looking in
girls windows and [__] like that but I'm
just saying that that's usually
indicative that's how serial killers
start like sexual type serial killers
they a lot of them start as like peeping
Tom type things and then it escalates
and it seems like that's what this dude
was doing because he seemed to start out
in this one neighborhood like looking in
women's windows and a lot of people
complained about it but nobody really
did anything about it because big deal
it's like just a dude looking in your
window like chill out about it but then
he started breaking into people's
houses
and doing like attempted rapes and they
kind of took that seriously but not that
seriously it was really only later and I
kind of feel like if they hadn't caught
this
dude he absolutely would have become a
serial killer cuz that's that's kind of
right how it goes they start with
peeping Tom [__] then they're like oh
we're going to break in your house and
then we'll just just do rapes or sexual
assault kind of thing or you know but
we'll leave the people alive but then
like as it goes on then they start
getting into like torture and murder and
stuff like that it escalates so I'm just
like that's why you got to like all
these peeping Tom [__] like take that
seriously I'm not saying like the chair
stereotypical pattern though is that
they get arrested and go to jail first
and then they get toughened up and
hardened up and prison and they come out
and then they start to kill they go back
to the serial rate but then they murder
too cuz then like we don't want any
Witnesses right and then they've kind of
sexualized the murder part of it that's
not always the way it happens like the
toolbox murderers weren't like that they
just started yeah it's not across the
board but it is a very common it tends
to be that it it escalates over time the
the toolbox dudes were just [__]
psycho [__] I don't even like dudes
like that I don't think dudes like that
can be
helped some kind of weird mental
problems because I definitely do I think
most people can be probably noral
psychology no I definitely do think most
people can be helped but there are some
outliers like that those dudes I think
those dudes were victims of damn [__]
lead poisoning that was during the time
yeah I don't think there was anything
you could do to rehabilitate that was
during the time of Let It gasoline you
just need to put them as far away from
society as possible and if you have
[__] brain dere if you have brain
damage from lead poisoning your
psycholog is not going to be
normal be real
hostile and I think that's what happened
to them that was during the time of Leed
gasoline yeah lot of the real worst real
bad serial killers during the time when
Le gasoline was everywhere and I think
that was definitely a factor and they're
breathing those lead particles and not
everybody's reacting that way to it but
some people are
you know people that have [__] kind
of bad histories and bad upbringings
anyway that lead poisoning is making
them [__] getting rid of their
inhibitions making them more aggressive
yeah that's what I think part of that
is yeah Tammy said Jenny have you ever
heard uh ever read the boy called it I
have I've heard of it but I haven't read
it um about a child Abed by his mom that
boy went through hell and never turned
into a serial killer yeah that's the
thing that's why I don't think think um
abuse is Ever Enough there always has to
be some underlying genetic component
because a lot sadly a lot of children
are horribly abused by and a lot of them
most of them honestly turn out okay I
mean you know what I mean at at least
functioning they don't turn into serial
killers they don't but a certain small
percentage of them if they have some
kind of genetic component um yeah
talking about peeping Tom thing yeah
it's murder hor is talking about pep and
Tom too um yeah the peep and Tom thing
[__] that's dudes that could a lot of
times become rapists because it's
peeping th is it's not consensual it's a
dude who's getting off on
voyerism about somebody about looking at
somebody that doesn't know that they're
being looked at that's what the fetish
is it's the whole non-consensual thing
is you're stealing it you're stealing
Vision you're stealing the way it looks
later on you going to steal the way it
feels great I mean yeah that's a pretty
obvious escalation yeah if you're
willing to it's the same kind of dudes
that will like install cameras in like
public bathrooms and [__] like that and
it's not like these dudes can't get laid
they get laid [__] even murder Hornet
can get laid even that [__] get
no they can get laid that's not what it
is they want they're they're fixating on
the
non-consensual they can't get off unless
it's yeah it's got to be against
somebody's will right which like I said
I don't know if surreptitious yeah I
don't I don't know if I'd call it a
fetish because fetish is usually between
consenting people it's a fetish but it
is kind of like fetishistic in that
sense it's a it's a fetish where that's
kind of the only fetish right that's the
only way they can get off is by somebody
like not being aware that they're being
watched or not being aware that they're
you know you know obviously like being
raped and stuff some dudes can like only
get off
on the woman not wanting it yeah which
is [__] up that's [__] up well I
think it's a Madonna [__] complex if
she wants it therefore she's a hoe if
she doesn't want it then she's a [__]
virgin yeah and he wants the good girl
the good girl doesn't want it which
that's some weird it is very weird
almost religiously inspired thinking
well and some of it might have come from
that yeah might might be where it comes
from because I mean whether you're
religious or not all of those ideas have
kind of seeped into the culture at large
unfortunately yeah a lot of prudish
religions are kind of rape
prone yeah
yeah that does seem to go hand in hand
doesn't it yeah isn't that interesting
yeah no I know why that is we're not
picking on Islam Christianity was like
that too uh yeah I was thinking of both
Christianity yeah and because they're
very similar in a lot of ways yeah
Christianity Judaism also but I don't
know what's happening there it's kind of
a that's a small world and they're
spread out in a diaspora so say for
Israel and I went to Israel and that's
just a part of town it's like California
you know [__] uh so I don't I don't
think I don't think they're [__]
prudish in Israel from what I saw I had
never heard that particular I don't
think I don't think Judaism is a big
factor of Islam I think it's is a big
factor in Israel I think just normal
life is the factor there it's kind of
secular but the way it felt to me I kind
of feel like that's what most places are
like yeah although they were they were
up holding dietary laws I go to a downn
Pizza Hut and try to get a pepperoni PE
cheese pizza we don't have pepperoni
that's pork I was like oh yeah yeah yeah
and you have any like [__] do you
have anything with beef says you you
can't put beef on cheese that's cooking
a right cooking a [__] Cal in his
mother's own milk we can't do but see
that's kind of might be the same thing
as can you give like some even some even
some places in the United States yeah uh
per primarily those that were um you
know uh kind of settled by Catholics or
something like that back in the day it's
just like oh well we do fish on Fridays
and we do this and that and the other
thing which I don't you know I grew up
in Florida so I don't really know about
that but I have like heard about that
well grown up in Brazil which is a
Catholic country the cath the the the
Catholics are not sexually aggressive or
perverse to speak of in outside the
Norms because in Catholicism in that
system of Catholicism it's Christianity
some [__] Protestants don't want to
accept that that's Christianity that was
the original Church y'all all seem like
just Christians to me like I said I'm
I'm my atheist ass just all yall is like
different flavors of the same thing I
like Catholics Catholics are cool
because they got cooler uh Cathedrals
that's for sure mus love the stain glass
I love that another thing is I love the
aesthetic in the in the Catholic system
you can pretty much do anything as long
as you confess as long as you confess
yeah go do some hail mares that's fine
yeah so no matter what you do very
forgiving which is kind of a good system
yeah you know me being Southern you know
F it's all Southern Baptist [__] it's
fire and brimstone you're going to hell
it's more like some out of Isis you
that's no fun at all but [__] no
Catholicism I liked it I mean [__]
you got [__] going to Catholic bass
you TR [__] prostitutes [__] um
confessing to their sins of prostitution
and [__] they're like yeah that's a
bummer it's okay but then they go back
out and you know they're don't do it
again I'm going to have to do it again
oh I'm going to do it again I'm going to
have to do it again I'll just have to
come back next week and tell you all
about doing it again cuz I got to put
bread on the table you know what I mean
but I think it's a healthier
system yeah if me if you if you're if
you're Pious like that or you believe in
a God then it's better if you have a
system of confession and going yeah I
did it I'm try not to do it again I mean
the fact that they acknowledged that
like people are going to do that [__]
like I said to me you know I not raised
religious and to me it just seems like a
huge waste of time cuz I'm just kind of
like why don't you just like forego all
of that and just be like yeah I'm going
to [__] up and I'll I'll atone for later
I'm not I don't need to go to a church
and say oh I did this and that I'm just
like yeah I did this that's [__] up
I'm not going to I'm going try in Brazil
religion was an experience you go to
listen to the music and to have to
experience a a a
spiritual
Zen you know I get that from other
things though that's what they're doing
what they do though I've always got that
from other things that's their
Traditions yeah well like I said I'm not
[__] on it I'm just saying that like
I never I didn't grow up without
experience so it's just kind of like I
always got that feeling from other
things but they had an alternate system
too it was kind of met mixed in with it
and I used I used to go to this too they
have makumba which is kind of like kind
of like Santa Ria but it's a Brazilian
version of it and a friend of mine took
me to to a couple Mumba rituals where
they're kind of doing the same thing
cast out demons uh trying to get good
luck getting rid of bad
spirits it was essentially kind of
Christ kind of Catholic also yeah well
there's a lot of Catholic mix yeah they
had some Catholic saints up there on the
Altar and then they had some other ones
that were more kind of like the people's
Saints like you know what I mean [__]
just common Brazilian yeah they just
kind of like coopered they were like oh
this is nice we're just going to throw
this into our [__] all right right this
is cool we're just going have a ritual
sure and U kind of like V voodoo
but yeah and Voodoo did that also it's
it's cross-contaminated withas
Catholicism yeah right it's Catholicism
across with like African folk religions
is what that same thing in Brazil yep
and I I saw it all as legitimate all is
it is all is equally legitimate in that
system sure yeah that's kind of the way
I see it too like I said and it's I
guess it's easy for me to say because
I'm not religious and I wasn't raised in
any particular religious thing so it's
like every like whatever works for you
man well you're surrounded by people
people that are trying to help you you
got a priest that's trying to help you
he's going smoke on you you got dadc and
girls there you know what I mean shaking
and as long as you're not trying to like
voice it on anyone else or trying to
like just you know that's I don't have a
problem you've gone there to [__]
cast off some bad luck and get good luck
and [__] get the spirits on your side
to pay for what you've done that type of
deal and you know if people want to do
that it's like who am I to say N I found
it [__] fun yeah fascinating and fun
yeah so I understood why they did it
Zan said Jews don't mix meat and cheese
together that's when I said I'm out beef
and cheese yeah only thing I can get on
the pizza was a [__] shrimp he's like
no cheeseburgers [__] that no only I
could get on a pizza pizza only meat I
could get on a Pizza Hut pizza was a
[__] any religion that said I can't
eat a cheeseburger I'm just I'm not
about that yeah Life's too short to not
theologizing to us all like all three of
us it was me and Chino and another guy
from we were all army guys there what we
have there we have dietary laws here
we're like what does that mean you know
we had no idea what the f like I said I
could find other [__] to eat but still
it's just like why why would you want to
impose that on
yourself I was in Israel man we were in
aot I know but and well we want a pizza
with cheese and meat on it we have
shrimp said okay yeah yeah yeah so we
just got that that's good too yeah but
like I said to me it's it's just kind of
like it just seems like rules for the
sake of nothing yeah that's that's all
it's just like you're denying yourself
joy for no reason whatsoever that's
that's how I kind of they're going to
their books man I get it but I read lots
of books too but yeah any one of them
said you can't eat a cheeseburger [__]
that I'm not going to no cheeseburger
just Burger I'm G to listen to that you
have Burger but not
cheeseburger I mean burgers are good too
yeah but cheeseburger is also good okay
Jen let's go ahead and [__] kind of
wind this up how far are we going I me
almost like far down so okay like at
this point up to we're almost at that
so to this day several of the of his
friends and colleagues as I mentioned do
not think that Ivans was the person
responsible for this do I believe that
I'm not entirely sure uh he did have a
lot of very uh quite severe mental
illnesses which may have at least
according to him um made him do [__]
that he didn't entirely remember that
does happen Victor says shrimp isn't
kosher I don't know if it's kosher or
not but they gave it to us at Pizza Hut
all right they just said that they
couldn't they didn't have pork at all
and that they couldn't mix beef with any
kind of cheese or
cream but they get they had shrimp they
can mix shrimp with cream maybe Jews
didn't eat shrimp I don't know but they
had that that's what they had it's just
very funny to me that like something
that was written in a book like 2,000
years ago that's about something so
trivial like you can't put together like
meat and cheese or whatever it's like
we're still following that now I'm like
really yeah this is back in '93 okay
1993 so I was just like well what pizza
can we have that
has cheese on it and some meat and they
say you have shrimp on it that's what
they gave I mean that's good too but
yeah that's what they gave us cuz shrimp
isn't considered meat yeah I guess not
it's not considered meat even though
it's I don't understand it it's an
animal I'm not je yeah I'm not Jewish
and most of those Jews didn't seem to be
Jewish to me either okay just to say
like I said it just seems like weird
arbitrary yeah [__] to make your life
more difficult yeah for no purpose I I
don't really know why you would want to
make your life more difficult life is
difficult enough um without imposing all
of these arbitrary rules on the [__]
that don't mean anything well okay I'll
just go ahead and put it out you know if
you you're in the comments section
either [__] listening to this record
or if if you're from Israel maybe you
can explain it that's what they gave us
to eat um and like you said that was a
while back so yeah I don't know if it's
still like that now but that was like in
93 you know and it was in a lot in a lot
and we were partying at the [__]
dolphin Club where they had the Dolphins
I think it's gone they got blown up
blown up by a terrorist attack but they
had a they had a a Pizza Hut down there
me and three other guys went to it we
were the only Americans in there at the
time had fun there though I I liked it I
liked Israel we used to go there for
vacation when I was stationed in Egypt
did you find any hookers no not there no
hookers in Pizza hell no why would you
need hookers in Israel man they had
girls there oh okay yeah so you're right
no they had the hookers the hookers were
only in Korea to defend the Korean
civilian women from us they were trying
to keep us [__] Under Wraps man you
gotta wa you got to watch man Tom's dick
it'll just Rove all over it's like the
wandering wom [__] it is why the
wander womb Theory we talked about that
yeah we were talking about that last too
I was just like that always kind of made
me laugh like thinking about like my
womb popping out just going like walking
around like with little shoes on and
stuff yeah yeah that just makes never
can't tell what'll happen who knows what
she's doing she's doing all kind of [__]
while I'm sleeping yeah she could be
[__] all kind of dudes I don't know
about it although if a dude wants to
just [__] a random womb it's walking
around all disembodied with shoes on
you got a question that dude's motives
really so there's a whole thing but I
don't know I think I even made a t-shirt
about that wandering womb we need to go
back and look into that um zanada says
you guys still haven't done a show on
the Narco Witch Doctor zero killer in
Mexico adalo constanzo no we have not
where's my pen I was going to write that
down I think there's a pen over there
give me a pen and a piece of paper I
thought I'd put one over
here I do write this stuff down although
the
show I guess not the next show but the
show after that's going to be the
Valentine show so maybe we should do
killer couples again although I think
we've covered most of the main ones let
me write
down ad do o castonzo okay I'm gon to
put that in the next
poll all
right so yeah so so where was I is there
anything else that I really have to
cover on this okay so as far as I know
at this juncture just to wrap things up
so we can talk about other things
because people clearly want to talk
about other things is that after Bruce
Ivans died committed suicide there
doesn't seem to be any weird [__] about
that like his wife found him he
overdosed on ibuprofen or whatever and
he bought like a a bunch of bottles of
it and just like took
it and as far as we know after he died
the FBI closed the investigation and
then they came out a little while later
and said yeah we're pretty sure that he
acted alone and that's the end of that
now most people accepted that some
people still think that there was some
kind like either that he didn't act
alone or that maybe he was a py or
something like you know obviously
anything like this is going to bring up
conspiracy theories I don't know how I
feel feel about that because I do kind
of feel like as I said his mental
problems and all of the circumstantial
evidence did make him seem like the
prime suspect he's a very good suspect
when and and and the attack
stopped yeah it didn't happen again
after I mean well the thing about it is
that it happened for a brief time and
then stopped and then like much like
years later they started looking into
him but see that kind of makes me think
that it was him more because who else
could it have been well and because I
don't think that his motive was
terroristic in the sense that he was
trying to do like something that
Al-Qaeda would be trying to do he was it
was a personal motive in the sense that
he was just messed up and he was just
lashing out 911 happened and it was an
opportunity where he could jump on that
bandw and he could just like lash out at
Society in general or at people who he
felt had wronged him or whatever um and
he maybe allegedly like got some jollies
out of oh I'm going to pretend I'm an
Islamic terrorist I'm going to send like
all this Anthrax to you know NBC and Tom
broka and
[__] uh the national Inquirer for
some reason might have just been the
attention you know senators and stuff
like that so yeah and I think that he
got off on the attention a little bit
Yeah well think about it 911 happened
they would talk about 911 constantly and
then they would mention the anthrax
attacks right along with it so every
time they're mentioning those an attacks
he's getting he's getting a [__]
thrill about how powerful he is that
he's got the entire that he's got the
[__] at that time one of the most
powerful [__] Nation on the planet
militarily he's got them scared trying
to [__] lash out so you feel real
important when that's going on and I
kind of feel like just from I didn't
know the dude but the impression that I
got of his personality type he did kind
of seem like the kind of person that
would get off
on attention like that yeah you know
what I mean like he you know he was a
scientist he was super smart and
everything and he could do [__] that a
lot of people other people couldn't do
he was also I mean he was married and he
had kids and stuff so he had like a
normal life but on the other side of
that he also secretly had all these
weird fixations on sorority girls and
all this other kind of [__] child sh
which I don't know if his wife knew
about um I've never read anything that
[__] for doing his 50s be worried yeah
and like by the time like when he died
um you know in 2008 he was 62 so this is
a dude that's okay should know better 62
yeah when he died in 2008 so when he was
doing this stuff he was in his 50s so
someone that should not still be
fixating on [__] from their college
Years I mean to say the least so the
fact that he's doing that yeah is he's
kind of regressive yeah he's kind of
that doesn't mean that he was doing that
I'm just saying that it's suspicious
because that's something that is not and
like I said he does seem to fit the
profile of somebody that would do
something like this yeah is all I'm
saying I'm not saying that I think he
did it I kind of do think he did it but
good
chance and like I said don't think he
had any political motive or anything
like that I think he just jumped on the
bandwagon yeah and was like this is a
way that I can make a splash and like
draw attention to myself it's a good
explanation because if it really were if
it really was Islamic terrorists they
would have had more anth they would have
continued to have used it you would have
seen more and more attack because the
whole point of that type of terrorism is
to cause Terror yeah and then to make
some kind of political result a response
and and those the letters that were
written are not coherent enough for a
group that's trying to get a result
there's no reason to attack this way
unless you want
something and he's they're not making
any
demands they're not saying why they're
doing it they're not pontificating and
that's the way a real terrorist would do
it real terrorist would be like you're
being we're striking you down because of
what you did over here and there what we
want and is this and for that terrorism
right yeah is is you're trying to get
your message across right and you want a
result from it and you continue to do it
until you get the result it's War it's a
it's a Warfare It's not personal yeah
this to me just seemed like a messed up
you're right this is personal he didn't
seem to care right that the people that
he was targeting Tom broka the national
Inquirer whatever like he didn't really
see or you know Tom you know uh Tom
dashel or whatever it didn't really seem
to matter to him that the people he was
targeting were not
affected he just
wanted attention it seemed like
and as I said I don't you know he's dead
now um and I will note that a lot of his
friends and colleagues still do not
believe that he ever could have done
such a thing and they know him and I
didn't so you know that has to be given
some weight too but it does seem like
there was a lot about him that people
didn't know on the other
hand
and he did have a lot of really um quite
severe mental issues which he did seem
aware of and did seem to be getting help
for although I don't think that it in
the end helped him all that
much if it wasn't him who else was it
why' they stop that's what I mean and
that's the thing yeah they kind of
closed the investig but you'd think that
this many years later had someone else
done it yeah some you'd think that
something would have happened and they
would have found out who it was and they
had access to high-grade Anthrax why did
they why did that stop
happening if you have access to it
you're going to use it yeah if this was
a terrorist group that had access to
this high
quality they would have kept doing it
yeah yeah I think the fact that he well
and I mean like I said only at the
beginning did they kind of think oh this
is terrorist that it's linked to 911 but
very soon they begin to hone in on oh
this is a really specific strain of
Anthrax so this must be somebody in the
US that is very very skilled at working
with this you know so they honed in on
the scientific Community or like people
that worked with that like pretty
quickly that's a good that that's a good
call right because they would yeah they
knew what they were doing they [__] up
at first because they accused that wrong
dude but like I said I can't even blame
them I can blame them for carrying it on
so long but I can't blame them for
wanting to investigate that first dude
hatf fell at first because he did look
kind of sus at first I get that but they
shouldn't have carried on for like six
or seven years because it was pretty
clear that he didn't do the [__] so they
should have like probably dropped it
prior um but I can't blame them for you
know this was a huge deal
yeah and they wanted to get this [__]
solved if you weren't alive during the
time you wouldn't understand it was a
huge deal yeah it was right up there
with the [__] Twin Towers attack they
thought it was a part of the same attack
at first they did yeah well because
that's what you would think it only the
first the letters were around the same
postmarked like just a week later so
everybody thought oh this is the second
wave yeah you know what I mean the
government jumped right on on that they
did because they're like oh yeah now we
we need to [__] can attack
Iraq well yeah they I mean and Bush
specifically said you know you need to
make this seem like it was yeah they
were like this is it wasn't combined so
we can use that but it wasn't absolutely
it wasn't connected and like I said if
it was this dude that did it I don't
even think it was politically motivated
in any [__] sense it just seemed like
this dude was trying to destroy
everybody had kick lashing out right uh
in the same way that a lot of kind of
like I feel like he almost have the same
mentality as some Mass Shooters yeah
where they're kind of like they've had
some [__] up [__] happen in their
lives some woman has [__] them over or
something like that their wife has left
them or whatever and they can't really
deal with it so they decide they're just
going to like make the whole world pay
because the whole world has [__] them
over apparently right and so they decide
they're just going to take everyone out
it doesn't even matter if they didn't do
anything or nothing to do with them or
anything like that and I kind of feel
like there's a specific type of person
usually a dude um that has that
mentality that a couple bad things
happen to me in my life I'm going to
make the whole world pay for it you see
this in Mass Shooters you see this in
Mass poisoners you see that kind of
mentality it's not
common but women have it too it's just
that yeah I'm just saying it's usually
dud manifests itself itself in a
different way sure oh it's going to
manifest itself kind of like that chick
back in the 1800s that was throwing all
the babies you know over the [__]
into the TS who a Milad yeah have we
done a show about her some kind of yeah
some chick who had you know or or a damn
uh chick working in a damn hospital as a
nurse and she's killing all the [__]
patients you know it's just a it's the
same kind of it's the same kind of
person it's just the gender is different
the way it manifests yeah man because I
kind of feel like and like I said this
is a this is a broad
generalization but generally and this is
not true of everybody so don't at
me dudes when bad [__] happens tend to
exteriorize somebody else cause that
yeah women when bad [__] happens I cause
that yeah generally not everybody's like
that and that's why most of your mass
Shooters and people like that tend to
tend to be men because when bad [__]
happens if two or three bad things
happen to a person my wife left me I
lost my job blah blah blah everybody
owes me yeah like everybody C like you
all caused this [__] all y'all I'm GNA
take everybody out and so they tend to
do that women tend to turn inward I did
something to cause this I'm a terrible
person it's my fault they'll do that
kind of [__] not everybody but women
tend to turn inward and blame themselves
men tend to blame others yeah and when
women start killing people they they
start killing people and then they try
to make it so the deaths cause sympathy
for them yeah you know which is like
lunch house and by proxy right when
women are serial killers it's usually
now you get some outliers like I said
like alien waros or like Bel gunis or
somebody like that who was just killing
for kind of like a male seral killer
alien waros was kind of like a male
serial killer um Bel gunnis I kind of
feel kind of like a male serial killer
but just a very um practic serial killer
she didn't really give a [__] about the
people she just wanted money and so the
people were just not people to her they
were just obstacles to her getting money
so just like well here's a person that
has money so bam I'm just going to hit
him in the head of the shovel and bury
him and just take their checks or
whatever so she was just very pragmatic
let's call it
that you don't see and we've talked
about this before you don't see um
female serial killers that are very
sexually Orient you know motivated or
fetish is you know fetishistic you don't
really see that a lot in Ser I'm not
saying it doesn't happen they don't have
a sex drive for it it well it's not the
same it's not the same it's not the same
you don't really see that they're going
to be more like black widows if it's
sexual right like I said women kill
generally for pragmatic reasons which is
usually a prophet yeah like um you know
this is a rich dude I married this dude
and then I'm going to like push him off
a boat or something like that cuz I'll
get his for you know what I mean they
don't kill because it's emotional or
anything like that about vengeance so
much no um it's it's usually very
practical sexual it's usually very
practical reasons whereas Ser male seral
killers they tend to have a weird you
know a certain type of male serial
killers tend to have a weird sexual
fixation with it yeah and like we were
talking about with the dude what was his
name Michael uh Mueller right Mueller
Mueller yeah yeah that was that dude's
name that was on American nightmare that
would I mean he was kind of weird for a
rapist but he was a like you said a Don
Juan style rapist which is rarer than
your kind of more power BTK style rapist
but they do have some Don Juan style
rapists that kind of think
they're I don't want to say they feel
like they're doing the women a favor
it's not exactly like that but they see
themselves as a nice guy who's they see
themselves as a good guy yeah they're a
nice guy who's role playing and that
they're pretending to be a bad guy to
alleviate the responsibility off of the
woman so she doesn't have to make the
decision and she can have the sex UNC
consensual it's not her fault it's his
fault and therefore she's still clean
yeah that keeps her from being s keeps
her from being yeah sure yeah and he
likes her he you know now he in his mind
he's rationalized that he kind of that
he's caring for
her yeah that he cares and he did the
dude that when you compare compared to a
lot of other power rapists he did care
for her took her
home uh he was when the cops [__]
tried to put her in jail he came to her
defense it's just that he's a rapist
yeah okay but he doesn't make don't
forget that he he he doesn't make that
connection though he doesn't see himself
he doesn't see himself like that that
all right he's like yeah yeah she went
through that she went through it like a
trooper it wasn't her fault it was my
fault I did it but I love her you that's
that's that's what he's doing you know
like she had not her fault she's
pristine you know that that's that's the
he's getting off on that I got a good
girl yeah that whole [__] Dynamic man
that
yeah man that documentary [__] me up
she was so brave now you know it's real
well then I wonder too because he's
doing that if you don't know the story
like I said I'm not going to like break
it down but it's not a review or
anything like that but it's just kind of
like you know she got kidnapped yeah out
their house like she was in bed with her
boyfriend whose name was Aaron yeah she
got taken out the house put in a trunk
and taken God knows where yeah and she
was held for like yeah she was held for
40 48 Hours something like that two or
three days and then they let her go but
you know she was raped a couple times in
that time period and he had an excuse
and everything of why he had to have SE
why he had to do it and he and he felt
really bad it's like well all of I'm in
this group that kidnaps people for money
for rantom yeah and we have to do this
and we have to have sex on video because
to make it look like you are so I can
use that against you use that against
you you have to like for leverage
because if you come after me I'm going
to say that we were we're just lovers
and you know what I mean so we have to
do this is for my security and [__] so
you got to pretend that we're that
you're into it that you're into this all
right this is you know that way you
can't go to the
cops that's and then he goes he does it
once and then he goes and then he stages
a fight between three other fictional
[__] we don't even know if they
were there he said it's not good enough
because you're wearing we have to do
you're wearing a blindfold so we I have
to tape your eyes shut so it looks like
you just have your eyes closed that like
we're doing this because got two out of
that right and then he go oh the [__]
fell through I got to take you home you
know and I think he told her the ransom
was paid didn't he I don't I don't know
if he did the r and the weird thing was
the ransom was only $15,000 yeah and the
thing about it I don't think because all
Aaron could come up with he said cuz he
did call his bank it's like how much can
I and they said we could they could only
give him 3500 yeah and he told the
kidnappers that well I can only get 3500
and then they stopped talking to him
yeah so for a while they thought Aaron
the boyfriend had staged all this yeah
and that he had killed her but then when
she turned up
alive then they thought it was her that
she was faking
and for a long time they thought that
and they just like [__] on both of them
for setting all this [__] up and it was
like really horrific and he comes to her
defense he's sending evidence saying no
no I and then the rapist comes forward
later and he like no that it's true I
did this and he sent pictures of where
he kept her all it was the craziest
[__] story it was because he doesn't
want her to be blamed but say then it's
just kind of like I I don't know this
kind of bothered me because there was
this whole thing where you know um Aaron
and uh Denise her name was
um you know they obviously they found
each other and got back together like
after and they got married later and
they have two kids now and everything
like that and she was like super worried
about what he would like that he would
see her differently because of her being
raped two times yeah and I kind of
wondered if he did like he didn't seem
to but no I think he felt like he had he
had failed her he couldn't defend her so
well he was I mean to his I mean he was
drugged they drugged both of them they
injected them with nyell or something
like that and she was like yeah I just
[__] wanted to get through it say
okay let's get this let's get through
this [__] you know what I mean I'll
put well the first one she just
dissociated yeah the second one she I
was just outside my body he said it
wasn't good enough you didn't look it
didn't look like it was consensual we
have to do it again you got to look like
you're into it and she went through it I
mean she thought that they were going to
that he was going to kill her well she
was scared to death so she don't blame
her I would also because people somebody
that would do that would also absolutely
kill
you she had no choice now would would
that guy kill her I don't think he would
have killed her at that point in his
career he would have maybe [__] 10
years later as far as we know he didn't
kill anybody but I think for [__] he
would have escalated to that had he
still been running around eventually and
that's why I'm kind of glad they caught
well they should have caught him before
he did it the weird thing is is that see
this is something that [__] people
can't make he saw himself as a good guy
yeah he did yeah and he did he's a good
guy with these weird fantasies that he
he wants and he he likes this weird
kinky situation and and he's protective
of these women that he's [__]
abducted he had a whole thing he put her
okay he took her from her boyfriend's
house they were sleeping he was going to
take the other girlfriend well yeah that
was the whole thing he said I don't know
if this is true or not but he said that
he was actually targeting his old
girlfriend actually his ex- fiance but
they had broken up not that long before
Victor said the boyfriend was good
looking too made him gay Vic you were
gay forever bro he was actually you were
gay in in the after life before you were
born but so I mean and I don't know if
that was true I don't know if he
actually was targeted the old
girlfriend's name was um Andrea but they
had broken up at some point before and
it was apparently like a pretty
acrimonious breakup and they all worked
together too which was pretty [__] up
up so I guess there had been some kind
of like
um uh tension I guess in the
relationship between Denise the new
girlfriend and Aaron because Aaron was
still talking to the ex like texting her
and saying oh I still care about you and
blahy blah and like his Denise like
found out about that was like bro what
the [__] is this like that's your ex
like let's leave that all in the past so
they were kind of having a fight about
that but so apparently what happened was
that some bu
broke into their house shined
flashlights and like laser lights in
their face and then
put like swim goggles on them that like
that had tape over them so they couldn't
see anything and the
person said his name so they knew who
these people were they you know referred
to them by name and mentioned something
about having a wet suit on which I
thought was weird but you know he
sedated both of them like he had a
syringe that had I believe it ended up
being I think it was nyall and maybe
diazapam like in the syringe so he um
sedated both of them and tied them up
and everything like that so Aaron was
tied up and like fell asleep and like
while that happened like they took her
they took the girlfriend Denise like
right out the house put her in the trunk
of a car took her someplace I don't even
know where it was and held her someplace
and the dude said the whole time that
she was in captivity that he was part of
this group of people that kidnapped
people for money and it's like I'm
really sorry this happened this was
actually intended for his old girlfriend
they never did explain that um he was
going to he was going to abduct that one
but what they found out later was
stalking people was that yeah when they
looked into like the crimes that this
[__] had done in the past was
that it seemed like he wasn't part of a
group or nothing like that it was just
that he really seemed to be into like he
stalked his victims for a Time
beforehand because I think all of the
victims that had been either raped or
attempted rape prior had said that he
had referred to them by name he knew who
they were so he had been stalking them
for some time I think before like he
broke in and did his whole weird started
off taking pictures of him like a
Peeping Tom yeah and yeah he had been
like reported as a Peeping Tom yeah like
um before that time so like I said you
got to watch his people always es the
Don Juan rapist is very
delusional they're so delusional that in
one
case um dude breaks into a girl's
[__] house does this thing with her
[__] she goes along with it and
afterwards she's like that was amazing
can I have your phone number and he's
like yeah sure I'll I'll come back and
see you again I mean can you imagine the
gives her his phone number and his name
because of course of course she wants to
call him back in his mind when can you
imagine she goes right to the cops
[__] narcissist and as soon as she
left she was probably dumbass yeah
that's what I would have said but I mean
can you imagine like in a way man that
chick is a hero yeah I can't I don't
think I would have had maybe I would
have but I don't think I would have had
the presence of mind or the calmness or
anything like that to act like that oh
no they're having towards somebody that
had just done that to me I got to go now
because like I said I'm not good at like
pretending so I'd been like you get the
F like I probably just would have
stepped on his neck or whatever
so just like pretending to be like yeah
that was the best thing ever and it's
just like that would have sounded super
in bed having cigarettes together I got
to go baby I know you go do oh you call
me back give me your phone number I'll
call you back and then as soon as she
left she's like stupid
[__] stupid [__] but
yeah she just she reported him and I was
like man that girl's my hero that girl's
my hero time shut down yeah it probably
is it's 11:00 all right I mean we mostly
talked about the topic right no we we
covered it I mean we got all all the way
to the
bottom I always like Wonder after
because I'm just like holy [__] man I
got to put the food
away okay got th all right but yeah I
mean hopefully you guys enjoyed the show
this evening I had a good time so
hopefully you guys did too um we will be
back on Friday night for the Sidetrack
show like I said at some point either
this weekend or Tuesday I'm going to
post something new over my scare Salon
I'm going to do the um Night Gallery
it's going to be season 2 episode 7 8 9
10 11 12 that's what I'm working on
right now um so I'm hoping to get that
up sometime either this weekend or next
week sometime because I haven't posted
anything on there for a long time but
yeah so that's the next thing I'm going
to do but we will see you guys again on
Friday night for the srack show which is
always my favorite so thanks for
dropping by this evening hopefully we
stayed on topic most of the time enough
for people not to leave
and we will see you guys again on Friday
night good night